I can't forget about it.
Forget about it.
Okay.
We are going to do a quick recap.
Last time you guys were following hello through the corridors of this industrial complex.
As you go deeper and deeper, you fought through mechanical arms trying to make minced meat out of you.
You fought through test dummy armors trying to, I don't know, obliterate you.
And then eventually when you entered the cog core, some chimeras sent by hello surrounded and tried to feed you to the machine.
While that was happening, Daniel woke up and he fought alongside with you for some time.
But in order to escape with Chloe, he turned against you.
You fought a little bit, Bob refused to kill Chloe.
And after that, Ben just landed straight through from the roof onto the platform that you're standing on.
Then Veil and Serika showed up.
Bob is non-conscious.
Daniel in an attempt to kill, whale, try to attack him.
But he wasn't successful and was knocked out later by Serika.
And at this point, everyone from the spiders is unconscious.
You guys are just waiting to see what happens next.
Did I miss him?
Who left?
Here.
All right.
So.
What was the plan?
We're trying to convince the, what is the Daniel?
I can't figure out.
Yeah, we're trying to convince him to fight with us and destroy this place and to learn about what happened on the island with the rings.
All right.
So you are in the Cogwork Core.
You see the light pouring in from above where Ben basically crashed through.
Right now, I think you tied Ben, at least with the ropes that you had.
And then you got over him. So if he wakes up to knock him out, because the whole plan was to talk with Daniel.
You start to hear a loud heartbeat through from where Ben is.
And the heartbeat keeps increases, increasing in like a tempo. And you soon see Ben's muscles twitch a bit as he starts to gain consciousness.
You want to whack him?
I'm whack the mint because the whole point was for a.
Circa and whale to talk to Daniel and convince him to join us.
Okay.
So that way they could talk more.
So I'm knocking big dude out just so they could have that conversation.
I mean, you can try to roll the forehead with the skillet.
Okay.
Hope you're all ready for me to fuck up.
Right.
So if he's we setting up.
If he's tied up.
Would it be with the bandit.
Yeah.
He's also just waking up.
So I'm going to do two will hit do the damage just so I know if you can knock it knock him out with this or not.
Now that's barely I think if you got 10 I think you would knock him out.
So you hit Ben and the your skillet just banks where where are you hitting him.
His head body and on the head.
Okay.
So your skillet just bangs on his head.
You see a small dent in your like highly chisel out skillet because you've used this as a weapon for so long.
So you can always keep kept this I kept it like reinforced but you still see like a small thing on it as it just clashes with Ben's head as he goes as he grows like a low girl.
Yeah.
Guys he's waking up.
While he is kind of getting ready you see like the ropes that you tied it up with like stretching and slowly and slowly just pieces of it just snapping off.
Well that is happening.
Oh God.
You see Daniel pipe up a bit and he goes.
That's enough Ben.
I'm tired of this.
They'll get what's coming to them soon.
You tried brother.
I know you did.
I understand.
Finally somebody has some sense.
He looks towards Ben and he tries to just calm him down a bit.
He continues.
I'm going to hit him again.
You want to hit Ben again.
All right.
I want to knock it out.
Okay.
That's going to hit with the damage.
Oh God.
I'm going to hit Ben again.
looking about T the it goes you're the captain right look there's definitely more
it play here than we thought I don't know if it's hallowed doing or someone worse I know he was
cruel okay I knew hallowed you've known him for a while but this whatever this is this is
pure evil this is worse than what happened on the island look I understand that you may not trust
me right now but I just wanted to help Chloe and get out of here I meant no harm except for the
first time you've got I didn't mean harm then for sure but we clearly cannot beat you and you
clearly have no intentions of killing us I hope I don't know about this fucking guy he points at
Roma but I think you have a clear mind that hey hey I don't want to kill nobody but I want you to
have a conversation with Serkhan well and from beginning of this I told you you're gonna help us
destroy this place I told you that from the beginning so either you help us destroy this place
or so help me God I gotta keep it new with my pain look I just wanted to set her free I didn't want
more blood you don't mean to hurt us I don't know how
so I'm asking for the last time just let us go Ben won't misbehave okay I can control him
Chloe's difficult but she'll listen to me what's your decision bro what what are you understanding
what aren't you understanding about this we need you to help destroy this place I'm gonna help us
we will God damn it help you fine all right let's cut the free yes just cut us off and I don't
know if my word means anything to you but that's what I am going to give but not until you have
that conversation we ain't we ain't cutting your ass free we'll cut the other two free until you
have that conversation at this point Sarah co will run up to Daniel she crouches down and as she
crouches down you see Daniel just trying very hard not to even look at her you just look sideways
Sarah co goes can't even look me in the eye huh listen here brat if you have the balls to come
after someone please look them in the eye when you threaten them while Sarah is like
braiding him will step up behind her he puts his hand on Sarah co shoulder as he goes
that's enough they have reasons okay I don't think I can convince you otherwise Daniel but know this
we really did everything in our power to save the island or at least the people as he says that
he looks down on his legs kind of padding them and he goes I was reckless I couldn't prevent it a
lot if I just didn't go all out from the very beginning but I am going to need some answers from you
tell me plainly because you aren't the original spiders I never met the number seven or number eight
I'm assuming that big guy he's pretty high ranked he should stay down by the way I don't know how
the fuck he keeps getting back up but what happened to the original ones what happened to the
spiders that were unrealized that day Daniel still not making any eye contact to
whale he just mumbles the six feet under whale kind of gets back up from the crouching as he goes
well guess what sister I don't think we can need to go after those eight losers
someone already did our job for us wonder if we'll be pissed sorry could go yeah he probably will be
quickly the
chuckle and the joy in whales body kind of kind of leaves them the atmosphere becomes very
thick it's almost electric and you can actually see like sparks of electricity flying off of
like wheels finger as he crouches down again and with like a dead serious look in his eye look
said Daniel as he goes tell me what happened to the tyrant what happened to silos
Daniel kind of intimidated at this point uh stirr subit as he says
uh our boss killed him
whale at this point just gets up as he goes ha all right so you guess I guess your kids aren't
messing around well uh that's all I needed to know it's up to you what do you want to do with them
if you want to let them go uh let them go we told you they got to help us destroy this place
they came right no I think the guy
he will takes you aside and he goes do you want me to tell them about the rings
they need to know what caused the destruction know that it wasn't you guys or else they'll keep hunting
you that's the reason that they're after you because they believe it was your fault
well who should say it wasn't if we didn't go there
probably wouldn't have happened you lost people in that as well though so
would you have done it if you you were going to lose people
of course not but let's beside the point that you don't think they're going to believe me
if it comes from me it doesn't matter
but hey if you're am I say I should tell them you should be able to hear this
so then I'll be like we could just show them the rings and show them like
what more proof would it be to see the fucking rings
okay because you said there's more right uh as well pulls out like the small blue box
you start to see like a shimmer of light glowing through the box and soon the
the box completely like exposes the light coming through the the whole place and
everything just goes like completely white as well as it goes oh shit not again
and I'm gonna move you guys some place else
we're getting transported
all right uh soon the glowing light subsides within the rings again but this time
you see all the blood that was pulling at the bottom just evaporated and the cogs at this point
below from below you see light pouring through and one of the columns said not again
what's happening I need to know oh I really thought it was we were about to evaporate like last time
but I guess this is something else okay okay so this guy is going to get out of here working now okay
okay as this happens you see one of the cogs that were blocking in this direction kind of opens up
and light is pouring through through this area well I don't know what is happening but the plate that
we are standing on seems to be heating up so I think we should probably just leave this place
yeah uh as you guys go that uh go to worst that area cerica just goes last one to make it there
please the deck for a week actually runs off uh
uh buff dude up uh while this is okay can you stop for a second
and you're not gonna move into the other area just on your own I'm gonna move you there fine um
I was trying to go there first
well I think you will get there first it's fine um so one of you will carry
these two I mean you can just let them go and just tell them to follow you or like make them walk
with you what's your option do you want to untie them or do you want to keep them tied
I want to untie them I do personally I'm gonna vote it on it I say vote on it
now please it's your it's your time I say on time
so I can be on the side okay as you let them go
yeah and time oh as you let them go um the big guide Ben just stands up as he just
slowly follows Daniel and Chloe he's just trying to still hold her anger is just
like following Daniel's lead um so we'll at this point we'll grab you Roma and Bob you
as he says well I think the ones with the wings can make it quickly there so
guys ready for a quick ride oh yeah oh yeah all right uh he grabs uh huh oh yeah yeah sorry let me
carry
sorry who carries what I mean is will strong enough to carry Roma he's a special skill yes he should be
able to carry both of you it's not like about strength it's just speed uh he will just
propel you further uh it's fine uh he grabs both of you and as soon as he like puts uh his hand
on your shoulders you just feel this blur of wave coming uh like towards your eyes you can't even
imagine like what what you're seeing right now and the other moment you're just near like a black
like caged door uh can you guys do a constitution save for me
oh boy good
okay uh well um I'll say cerca is just printing over there and she said this point left the map
these guys have left the map it's just uh you and that he's uh malphous so I'll assume
these guys are leading in front and you guys are following them
well the general also the big hole up oh my god
about this you're rolling privately or something
uh Roma you have succeeded Bob you get to the door and your world starts to spin
and you have to throw up now
yeah I'm not surprised
you don't have to make the concepts malphous and malphous as it was just for them because they
they were like being taken to that area
well you would have failed anyway yeah
the ones with the wings would have failed too
uh all right so you guys slowly make it there as you see cerca like just full sprinting
getting there too uh I'm assuming you guys would be like kind of
we've made circle out running as well
we've made circle out yeah so while these guys are running in front
cerca with her like tiny little legs you just just trying to full sprint you both pass cerca as well
and eventually you get to the door uh in front
yeah I mean both of you would be fast just felt these guys will also be kind of fast
so will at the end is just standing there waiting as he says as he shouts back to cerca
who's still running up while you all are just already they're waiting uh and he shouts
I have the speed speed fruit cerca
and cerca goes I said no double fruit abilities oh god
you did not want to say that you did not want to pick greek you never once said that
uh i can last word well those yeah you didn't you didn't say that yeah see these guys also heard it
so as all of you come towards that door uh there's no lock there's no lock or anything you can
go in directly it seems to be like an old abandoned workshop of some kind
open it okay as you go in Baptist all you see at this point is just this like dust filled
large like corridor and then there's like a big area in between with like broken and like old
stuff covered and dust completely it's completely abandoned it looks pretty old and this seems
to be like one of like the foundational buildings made before even this island was like made into
this whole fucking uh industrial thing um i'm gonna say sail whale in cerca and everyone else
I'm not gonna move every token it in uh but everyone else would also be here uh in the same
area well what you know i have a question for you you said this shits have
happened before you said not again okay do we got time where we can post up and have a meal real quick
like i just want to know well this place looks empty enough wait that's what i'm saying this place
looks a little safe like uh i need to take a breath like i need i need it uh you know what i'll
take a lap around the place and see if there's anything that i can find uh but i think you guys
should probably rest uh me and cerca will be on the lookout right i'm not that hurt anyway mostly
cerca thought so she's gonna probably have to take a break too uh let me do an investigation for
all male you see will just zip around uh the place oh my god but he comes back to you
aroma with like this shiny smile as he goes looks okay to me man
Daniel earn your key what he said Daniel earn your key your scout right scout the area
all right uh all right man you're is going to start to look around for any traps or anything
as well
if you don't look for anything useful investigation
measure be good enough uh he just looks around he goes and sees he says uh well other than these
footsteps leading up to the strab door that doesn't seem to be any
issues the trab door is like up upwards like uh you know attic uh stair kind of thing you pull it
and then like uh stair comes down uh he pulls it once and he jumps up he just looks around and he goes
this thing goes way up uh he's gonna jump down and puts the stair back up
i i don't want to admit this but i think me and everyone else all so can do with some rest
we're gonna just stay in this corner if you want to keep an eye out first feel free to
uh all three of them just go around uh in this corner as bends it's down and uh
clowey and Daniel both like put their backs against Ben as they just lie down for a second
is there like it's a workshop so like
there's gotta try to look around i'm gonna look around to see if there's like any food where i can
make some food real quick this is pretty old so any food you find would probably be moldy and stuff
like that but yeah you would be able to find like some vegetables and stuff like that but they're all
moldy and like rotten nothing can do or anything nothing uh basically like a giant dust molds
around the room uh you see a long oak table uh around here which is this matte uh broken
you see a bunch of yellow papers drying around uh in on this area you see a bunch of blueprints
which looks to be uh about this uh industrial like uh place exactly like uh
basically we take in everything designs of this place um uh i'm telling Bob that there's blueprints over here
as you walk around can you do investigation from your mama oh fuck me god damn it yeah okay
if you guys if you guys want to look around just just roll investigation whoever wants to look around
16 god damn it Bob mapti you're rolling privately amazing oh my god oh no words oh my god
malphous and bob you're just looking around and you did not see anything of notice
looking out of the window i just got kicked by a guy
yeah you did you did get kicked by a huge guy and just throw throughout all wrong um okay
roma adds you walk around here in this area you see a small like burnt picture frame uh as you turn it around
there's like two names crashed on it uh one uh on the left side with like the face of the picture
like kind of burnt on the other side as well but you do see a person in between the picture uh that
definitely seems like a younger hello uh the names inscribed on the left and the right of the
picture is rai and mirra uh rai seems to be a probably middle aged man and a mirror seems to
well be a woman of it like long black hair uh flowing backward uh yeah that's all you see
hey baptiste there's something here for you to hold on to this it might be important
you want to see the picture roma you also notice like with your uh like strong sense of smell you
notice like a residue of some burnt oil or something uh right in this area and you also find like in
one of the drawers of these tables you find a small notebook uh along with that you find
a couple boxes filled with liquor liquor not not not not liquor uh it's labeled as one of the boxes is labeled as
uh
the conductive dust while uh one of the goggles is there's a small goggle aside it in in the box
there's like a few wiles and on the wiles it says while of conductive dust uh and uh hey oh
Rob come come look at these boxes i don't know what this is yeah come look at these boxes
i i got the notebook still in my hand right yes in the picture uh okay if you want to read through
the notebook i can draw i'm gonna draw that inventory wherever you want to give it yeah i'm giving
it to baptiste like he going look through that shit okay baptize i'm gonna drop the notebook
in your inventory there you go you can send it in the chat for other people to read or you can read
it out loud whatever you want i'm also giving him the photo of mirrors today i dropped it in your
inventory it should be in loot right after mirrors uh sorry grandline log post i found it
i also gave him the photo bob you look into the boxes that uh Roma showed you uh you see
a couple of notes about what the box content is one of the things which is the
while of conductive dust uh it's basically says that uh a small glass while filled with flain flain
cluttering black grape powder that crackles faint faintly when exposed to air uh what it would do
according to you can you do in arcana you can just do it in intelligence actually no no no it's not
a tnd thing be a wizard bob doing arcana please
that's what i'm saying i gave it to the right man let's go
all right uh you can easily tell that this is some kind of dust that you spread to increase any
amount of lightning damage so if you apply it to yeah so if you apply it to uh something either like
weapons or on some one you can do three attacks in succession uh and do uh double damage
instead of the whatever the damage you were not double damage actually sorry uh
let me see one d4 lightning damage sorry uh plus if you gain uh you gain plus one outside of
combat if you're applying this to something outside of combat you gain plus one on attack heads
which for lightning damage only i thought it would be yeah i give it just just here just in in the
okay you can give that to zap those i'm gonna roll for it like how many wilds are intact and how
many are broken um gonna roll
you could even do it in the group chat yeah of the channel
yeah you can just drop that into the group chat i i'm gonna be honest i ain't reading that shit y'all
gonna have to read that that's what i'm saying give me the torque those versions you
you get holy shit both created you get eight miles of conductive dust mouthless uh bob you also see
a piece of goggle that might help you target enemies for ranged spell attacks
okay you better put it yeah i'm gonna drop those in well you better put that all you have
i dropped the goggles you can read the description to understand what it does
beber guys we're doing a short rest like uh you want to do a short rest you can do a long rest
whatever you want oh we're doing a long rest then fuck
look you know when in game you find a bunch of loot you know what's about to happen when you
find a bunch of loot we just want to make sure
long rest you can choose to do a short rest no no we do it if we have the opportunity to do a long
rest we do long rest them because i need my rage back i mean well i mean well did say that he'll
be on the lookout either way you probably won't take a long rest but uh the rest of you can i don't
think you know what long rest you know what that means yeah exactly we love love
shake it all right uh you guys can all roll for long rest i'm gonna roll for
very good long rest oh you don't have to roll but you know click long rest or
i was in one hp yeah
with the seed roe he died oh i'm gonna actually move Daniel and everyone as well here so i can do a long rest
through that
fuck i'll tell him to cook somebody a meal and give it to him like i ain't got shit on me for
ingredients i'd say you probably carry some stuff around with you uh but you can cook here but
you will be able to like give something to each to them which is basically what a long
long rest is like you just rest and stuff like that that's what i was hoping on yeah
oh how do you level up i'm just kidding all right uh who wants to read through hello journal
i am trying to but
it just goes on and on if you don't want to read it you don't want to read it we can move on
yeah no well you got to you got to read it because there's there's shit that fucking is probably
gonna somebody got to read it somebody get all right ridden get it and i'll give y'all this
in the office that that's what i'm saying like cuz i'm gonna tell you right now i'll say all of you are
just resting Roma you drop off some off like buried and like be some basic stuff that you had on
you to everyone while everyone is just in a corner resting uh Bob what are you doing are you
exploring the goggles are you resting oh a mouth is reading the sorry baptis is reading uh
eight-wild trade yeah i'll drop it to you you you can read the description to understand what
they do exactly i mean to go out to the hills so also i was like you know i'll do one before but i
was like okay but if it's like one while it won't make sense so i did two d if one and that's
great both fours and now yes fucking eight-wilds oh good good now you have it so now you have it so
i was thinking of getting something for roman that you but i couldn't really make sense like what
would be here but gold plated skillet just oh sorry sorry i forgot one thing there is some like
expensive looking metal along with those wiles by the way uh there's a missk item thing
so baptis if you want or anyone else want just add that into this if you can edit the item can
you edit the missk item missk items thing you give it to baptis reading the
i'm gonna give this i'm not listening to anything right now uh roman can you check if you have like
this missk missk thing missk items enlute
in my loot in my loot uh yes miss items can you see if you can edit it
is there an option to edit uh yeah i can and you just expensive metal
yeah just right let me tell you exactly what it is
mix of silver and golden
hola hola hola hola mix of silver and gold alongside some platinum alloy
it's basically like a big blob of uh mixed rare metals
you don't know what it's prices but if you sell it to someone you will find out
okay why can't i type here
okay there we go there we go there we go uh you said gold and silver with
platinum you said
okay about 20 pounds like the weight of the thing would be about 20 pounds
weight will be 20 not 200 okay
just save that so
all right
do you guys want to while in the meantime while they they're reading the journal
what do you guys want to do in the meantime
well we looked we looked everywhere in this office correct yes nothing nothing else really
makes much sense you just see a bunch of like burn blueprints stuff like that nothing else would
like make any coherent sense well i still want to take those blueprints yeah yeah you can
look through the blueprints to see uh what leads to where exactly like while i'm going to take
them and i'm going to give Bob has the other blueprints right or our most yeah so yeah i'm
so oh yeah so yeah i'm going to give him the blueprints to see if any of those match up to the
armor that he has uh so this blueprint whatever you have Roma is the blueprint for the island like
making the island itself for the armor blueprints yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah world for it
roll just straight intelligence and it's reading the journal all right
uh ten bob for all you can tell on the blueprints the core is just written as
uh by the way i have my phone what
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh what was it there's a thirteen there the two of us oh my god there's the worst ones you wrote so
oh yeah yeah uh uh
fucking i forgot the name of the core uh
oh yeah you see uh whatever the core was uh you see it labeled as the divine furnace
as uh you are now whatever your room you are in it's labeled as uh hallows
what do you call it workshop uh the trap door that you see here leading up to wherever it's going
that place is marked as graveyard okay maptees if you want to scrumge up your people and tell them
what's happening oh yeah the one i read a little journal looks like he wasn't surprised
he was like a little from brana says well they came here under the assumption that they could make a change
positively with someone called the doctor he doesn't provide the exact name but that's where he
calls him so doctor gave them well he created this core and initially how low didn't know what it
did but once he found out he tried his best to stop it but since he was already part of the system
he remained a cog in the system he lost brings in the system but he still heapsy going
even now but still he still tries to stop it and this is potentially going on in other places as well
he also talked about you guys you know look at spiders nest he thought about how you guys can hear
about your family but each one of you
and how he wanted better for you in a way how you gave him hope that he could change things
but he wanted to shield you off from it but i think he's too far going in the idea that he can't
ended without retaliation
so we have to do a form
or must be destroyed. Go ahead go ahead. Oh I said was the core must be destroyed
then gets up he comes to you as he goes can i look at that
now pass it to him. You pass it to him he takes it just stands there for a second as you
read through those doctor this is what he was not so well this time
what you know the doctor
yeah he's the one who gave me my legs back he's the one who does everything for us but we never knew
what i just now i hope not he hands you back the journal as he goes back and talks to the rest of
them about something you can't hear from this distance. Hey Daniel Daniel hold up hold up
hey show him the picture he might know those two you might know those two are
how to talk about them before there were his friends there were married couple
his best friends that's what he called them but he told us that they died some time ago
he just didn't know how exactly it says it in the journal. I know I read it.
they're part of the process but now we have to report this to
eyeless we at he looks at his legs and he goes i don't deserve these thanks
should just rip them apart. You shut your mouth brother.
You relax you're gonna help us destroy this so nothing else happens come on now
we don't kill them but we need your help. You have my help. The last thing I do
I will destroy this goddamn core. Stereka and Vail are quietly listening to this as well
as they go well rest up. It goes in the morning we had straight up
and we see what's happening. Come on Pimpsqueat in the morning I'm making waffles.
Oh Sarah goes fucking knocked out she sees sleeping she has not heard any of this.
Probably close that that's where he still says that you're fucking knocked the fuck out.
Shit. All right so. Wait. While we have time I walk up Memphis.
Memphis. Yes. Have you heard anything about the sister as a blade? Yes not about her but yeah I have
researched facility. What information did you get? He's somewhere on let me quickly look at my notes.
This facility is on G 45 and he's blue. G 45. Where was the island? Yes.
We just came from G 45.
That was all I heard. I'll try to find Bill and ask him if he still has that journal from
the bank that we took. Okay. Let me see where the fuck that you know is that why misplaced it or not.
Red maybe it was on red. Let me check. Not on red fuck me.
Now please.
Did fucking. Lines have it. Oh it might be on the line.
Story purpose it should be on whale or sarica. Yeah. I just don't remember. I just don't remember
whose character she'd I actually had on it. Probably saplings to be honest with you. Probably the other
saplings with the armor and everything maybe. God no. I'm sure you don't have that on you.
No you have it on you. Oh no that's how that's how I just gave that to you.
Red not. No.
I've dammit how also fucking delete everything from my own paying.
Reload do you have it? Uh-uh. That's I was just checking too just in case but no.
Uh the journal. No. I remember red had it technically and then through it. Yeah.
And you said whale picked it up. I know whale picked it up. I just don't. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah because we tried to make it. That's what we took but it's which it was. It just wasn't what they
were asking for. Mm-hmm. Just the items. Okay let me see. I'll over.
You know if I find it I'll let you know you can read it by time maybe.
We will have information on that mouth. We just need to find the journal that we missed
placed. It's on the ship bro it's on the ship. Yeah it probably is on the ship.
Hey yeah. The whale is gonna. He's gonna he's gonna say uh it might be with some of my stuff back on the ship.
Once we get back to the ship we'll look at it and see if we can get some answers or
actually. Yes because the boss is probably escaped.
All right guys let's get some rest. Let's fucking because in the morning we fuck shit out.
Everyone's longer than you. Yes. Yep.
Is this level up? Nope. No. No I said maybe.
You know okay. You said usually you have to learn where it's a level up and we sit.
No that's okay. We'll get the level up after this who gives a shit. Let's climb this ladder.
Let's go to this graveyard. Let's fuck shit up. Let's send notes. We will follow.
Yeah what are you saying Bob? I mean we need to survive to level up so.
True. That's the right. We have to survive for a week on the sea then that's when you level up.
Yeah. The rules keep changing. Yeah I know right.
It's like the goalpost keeps moving.
Let's kind of fucking ladder. We're sending Daniel first though.
Near the morning you get woken up by this loud siren that's just going off.
You can hear it here but the siren seems to be going off like in the main industrial area.
But you can still hear it way deep down in the core. It's so loud.
Well they know we're coming.
Only makes things more fun.
Everyone gets ready. You see the six folds both sailing way ahead.
I keep saying they kind of scratch it up a bit. You see whale pull out some of his like
corambits as he spins them and puts them back in his tool belt and goes well where did he go?
Yeah you're going to see Rome over there stretching like like a dad you know the classic
on the hands on the stomach.
That Jesus is going to crack his knuckles and start walking. Let's get this done.
Hold on Daniel goes first. He's the scout.
Come on I'll go behind you big dog like I'll be right behind you.
All right. Ben don't just come at the last. Don't try not to break the goddamn stairs.
Ben just nods as he goes.
He pulls the stairs down and he starts to climb up.
You guys follow through quickly as soon after you get out inside of
kind of torn apart building.
I'm going to move you here.
Oh shit.
You didn't see that.
Didn't see what I all I can see is a fucking doorway.
All I see is this.
Yeah so yeah I couldn't get like an open one. So basically inside this you see just
shattered like a building top and you get out of this area and you replace me.
Health is just token I keep.
I have placed all of these tokens on the map.
Yeah so you guys get out. Daniel is in front of you.
Baptiste at this point everyone is out.
Chloe and Ben are also with you.
Serican will or near you Roma in this area.
Well after you he points to you.
Baptiste as Daniel steps back.
Oh hell no Daniel you're the scout go.
Which way will we go out this door?
Out this door yeah.
I'll step out.
Captain.
Okay you just step out into this sort of graveyard but you do see on the ceiling this place is still like
pretty locked up it's like some abandoned area within like the buildings itself it's still
way beneath the surface of the actual island.
I'll just keep walking while looking around to just make sure.
Okay as you walk you see hello just standing near the tree on the
floor you can get.
Yeah I'm stuck in the door.
Sorry.
Move you ahead of it again.
As you guys walk through Baptiste you spot Roma at this point you can also see probably
that hello is just standing there at the corner.
He has a cigarette he smokes it.
He puts it throws it down crushes the cigarette.
He goes I see you finally arrived then.
Teams everyone's cleared the building.
Efficient.
Painful but efficient.
At this point I'll get monster.
Yeah maybe I am.
Well the way Lisa tried to save everyone that I could.
You might as well take the Japanese way out finish yourself off you know you're a monster.
You don't know nothing about what I've done.
I want you.
You literally turned your best friends into your project.
Are you going to stop him up Lisa?
You might as well sample who that stuff right now like go out with honor.
I'm letting Roma speak.
All right.
I mean yeah that is at cook.
At this point how was just confused like what?
I didn't do anything to them.
You literally in your journal you said you you let the doctor do I don't know.
Baptiste wanted to say it.
The doctor took his friends to help with the project.
Exactly.
Are you not the doctor?
No.
Do I look like the doctor?
I don't know what the doctor looks like.
I've never met him.
This is a flop.
Okay.
Horned.
Can I?
I'm going to talk to someone who has a brain.
Hey, what's you smell part of this?
You know what's happening into that core.
You're literally part of this.
Fuck that.
We're going to forget the doctor ship.
You still know what's going on with that core and you're allowing it.
You better sample who that ship because you allowed it.
That's what my friend.
I am planning to.
He you see him pull out like sort of like a remote thing on his one hand.
You see I was planning to destroy this place a long time ago.
But I never committed to it because I knew they just replaced me if they find out.
Now that let us get off the island first.
Someone has to die to make it make sense.
Yeah, that's what he can still be you bro.
But let us get off the island and then blow it up.
Yeah, you just take us with you.
He just ignores you.
He just keeps going and goes.
At this point the workers probably have left.
And I could maybe finally do everything I've done.
She go for you also see at here this grave it seems to be dug up and this grave covers like this whole area.
So dash to him and fucking throw him against that tree.
So as you guys are stepping are you going to go closer?
Hey bro, hey bro, like I said, let us get off the island first.
Okay bro.
Hey Roma as you're as you're making your way toward him.
You at the tree you kind of notice something above the tree as halogist takes one off.
It takes the hammer and goes.
Doesn't matter.
Beyond that here and this gets blamed on you.
And hopefully this never happens again.
While says that at the top of the tree you see kind of tendrils dropping down.
As he goes, halogos, say hello to my little friend.
It's not little.
You see a big blob of this flesh drop down
as a fuck.
And a malgamation of limbs.
A hideous silhouette that is part human, part mixtures of animals, both zone and fuse together.
Muscles ripple beneath like odd fur and scales on the legs.
It has many like telltul's pounding out of the like it's back as the mouth just drops like the jaw
of the one side of the face is just completely a jar as the monster screams.
And this will start the combat.
Awesome.
Is this the product of the core?
And there we go.
At this point, whale will ask you about peace.
Okay, this seems like a handful.
I'm a bit worried about the people here.
I don't think most of them could have made it.
He wanted me to go back and look if everyone's made it safe or do you want me to stay here and fight.
Can you follow me?
Everybody got out.
What?
Follow just said everybody got out.
No, he said they probably got out.
That's what I'm saying.
So we don't roll the chances.
You don't know.
So I'm just asking you what's your decision.
Do you want him to stay or do you want him to go and check on those people?
Go make sure everyone's out there.
You don't want any more innocence to be
subject to this.
Are you, girl?
Syracal, you're coming with me.
So he's going to point at Chloe and he's going to point at Syracal and he's going to take both of them.
Do you still want him to go?
Make it quick.
Yeah, I'll try to get here as fast as I can.
You see Will just grabs them and just runs off like right here in this direction.
I'm going to add Daniel and Ben to this encounter as well.
There you go.
Give me one to the snap.
He's a bit too big.
Let me fix that.
Probably not going to be that much taller than that.
Physique is a bit different.
So he still looks like a bit bigger.
Okay, there you go.
I feel like my token feels smaller.
I really, it's token feels smaller at this point.
In general, I get fever seen as well.
Because I think your token or your character art was pretty tall in the last character.
But I think I had it pretty zoomed in too.
Maybe that's why.
Maybe.
Okay, don't move.
Don't move.
You're in combat.
What are you doing?
Oh, sorry.
Let me roll for these guys.
Ben.
Daniel, my boy.
Daniel.
Oh my god.
What the fuck are all two?
All right, the combat begins with Roma.
Do you know what a boss Mars?
I don't even have to dash.
I'm in 35 feet.
Keeps me out of his range.
I'm going, I'm going for the original plan.
I'm moving up there.
Because what my normal speed is 40.
So I can still move up there and hit, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, you know what I'm doing.
I'm moving up there.
I can't, god damn it.
I should have just hit space.
Yeah.
God damn it.
All right.
So yeah, I'm moving up there.
I'm whacking his ass.
Just say, though, you dangerously close to the thing.
I, I, no offense.
We all got to have to get close.
Right.
We'll do something from a range would be fucking Bob.
Yeah, yeah.
But I'm going to hit, I'm going to take a whack at fucking oh boy.
Just so you know, for all intents and purposes,
hello is a human.
He has no ability.
He's nothing.
He just has a hammer.
That's fine.
Yeah.
He's the one who had, he's the one who had to remote right now.
Like, so that's why I hope it's, that's my whole goal is to get the remote.
Like, all right.
Do you attack?
Yep.
Recklessly skill it.
So that lets me swing with the vantage.
Yes.
I'm ready to.
Yeah, that hits.
You don't need to ask.
He's recently, he's a little like a person.
Oh, but I fucking do.
You, uh, you bonk him on the head as he like struggles a bit, uh, at the end of your turn.
Wait, this thing, I'm going to rage at the end of my turn.
Okay.
I just, I'm just attacking him right now and then I'm going to rage.
As soon as it sees you attack, uh,
hello, it will try to hit you with one of its tendrils.
Oh, wait, what happened?
Sorry.
I'm zoomed by activity.
Oh, what?
That's your match or something.
Sorry.
There you go.
Uh, there you go.
Does a 16 head.
Yeah.
Okay, let me do a tendril attack.
Uh, there you go.
I'm a 16 head straight.
So I'll just do the damage.
Sorry.
That's six 12 damage to you.
Can you make a strand safe?
To see if you get grappled or not.
No, you don't get grappled, but the tendrils kind of slosh at you and you will take, uh,
12s amount of slashing damage.
All right, next is Bob.
Hold on, but now I'm going to start.
Oh,
rage.
Okay.
Yeah.
As a bonus, right?
For your last action, I will say you raged after that.
That's what I, that's what's going to cause me to fucking rage.
You fucking touched me.
All right, Bob.
Go ahead.
Are you wearing the goggles or not?
I'm on the doctor's right.
Yes.
Okay.
So just make a roll and plus add, add plus one to the attack roll and plus one to the damage roll.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
This is not an attack spell, right?
So that's fine.
Oh, he fails.
Okay.
Do the damage.
You see the little, uh, ball.
Circle around, uh, this creature.
As it burns through the rotting flesh on its body.
And then I'm going to hide behind this gray or whatever.
All right.
Next is
at the end of your turn, this thing will
try to dash toward you.
Get the hell out of there.
Okay, right.
And it will
do a slam attack.
Let me see if it can.
Oh my god.
Oh, the closest one is probably you.
Okay, slam 22 hits.
Who's it attacking?
A Roma.
Come on.
I'm going to do a normal damage.
And it's going to slam right into you.
And you will take seven in the amounts of damage.
As it through, let me see.
Uh, can you do another strength says to see if you go prone or not?
Come on.
Big dog.
Yep.
Strength say.
I mean, it's good because you're a good at strength.
So it's lucky for you.
You're not getting fucking grappled or prone.
Okay, as this thing slams to you, Roma, you still kind of channel.
You're like devil fruit ability and the weight of that ability.
Transformation and you somehow block this thing, uh, to like push you completely off.
Uh, okay, Baptiste, you're turned.
Don't do something that I don't usually do for anything.
Let me check the range on this.
About 30 feet.
That's, I mean, you can move and then do the 30 feet.
Yeah.
I'm going to move up.
I'm going to move up and then right behind both the monster and
hello.
I want to drop.
Why is this not coming up properly?
A black hole.
Where which way?
Behind them enough to where it can pull them both in.
I'm on my iPad so it's not letting me properly measure it.
Oh my god.
Yeah, so it's not properly doing it on my.
All right, okay, just just point to where you want to place it.
I'll add that there.
Like back here.
I have to where it's 30 people in there.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to do that one.
Okay.
10th radius of the diameter as long as they're both pulled in.
I would have done that way.
30s range.
Yeah, 30 feet.
If I need to move closer, I still have to do it too.
No, what's the radius of the black hole?
10 feet.
So.
Where do you want to put it?
Because this is 11.
And they're still out of range.
I need to move a more.
Okay, here.
This is a place that's going to drag both of them.
Okay, but it will also drag the thing that bob through
and that will destroy it.
What about throw?
The fire sphere.
I don't think it's fear.
How did this boy?
It doesn't have an HP.
It's not an HP, but it's flavored as an object.
And the black hole will pull it in and destroy it
if it's an object.
It's an explosion.
Exactly.
It's got a constant explosion, which.
Let me check.
But he won't.
He wants a 10 feet radius.
Strand saving throw.
Once a field takes 2d6 force damage and you're pulled
10 feet toward the center
and not prone on a success.
They take half damage and you're not moved.
Okay.
All right, I'll say I'll say it probably won't get damaged,
but I just meant like it's a black hole.
But are.
These 12 strength.
Strand.
The monster fails it.
How low fails it?
Can you do 2d6 force damage?
Roll 2d6, that's it.
And they will both be knocked from.
Which will be this.
Actually, I'm going to burn his resistance
to resist this one.
There you go.
Can someone roll the d6 for me?
It's not letting me do it right now.
Yeah, I'm never going to do that again.
All right, one.
Oh shit, my bad.
Who did 611?
Which one are we picking?
Roma rolled it properly, so wrong.
Yeah, yeah.
20.
Yeah.
All right, you see, hello gets forced into like this small pocket
of just black void as he gets thrown into it.
And he will fall prone.
All that happens.
He coughs like a bit of blood as he looks at the monster,
which is basically unfazed by whatever's pulling.
It just keeps walking as hello goes.
All right, near.
You remember me?
Are the resistance for us to not know you at all?
Doesn't matter.
I'm sorry to wake you up from your sleep.
Make sure to destroy that machine.
Everyone is safe.
If you leave it be, they'll come after you.
You're right on the hope.
He looks at you, Roma, as he says that.
The amalgam at this point starts to work toward hello
and you'll just grab his head and just crush it.
Hello, Stead.
Oh, so he got sucked into the black hole like he wanted to.
No, no, no, no.
The black hole is like a small thing.
It happens for one second because if malphous keeps,
sorry, if apathy keeps it open,
then everyone would die.
So it's like a small like one second thing.
It gets pulled, but after that,
it does not have like any lasting effects.
It's just forced damage of like getting pulled.
But the creature just walks up to hello
and just crushes its head.
Is it?
Perfect.
Oh, my turn.
Your turn is over and I would say that's his action,
legendary action.
So he's burned through all of his legendary actions at this point.
It's Ben's turn and Ben will just not add Daniel
as he.
What's this moment?
Oh god damn it.
It's malphous.
He's gonna move 30 feet and then he's gonna do his breaker slam.
That will not happen.
Oh my god, whenever these guys fight for you,
they get weaker.
I don't know why.
All right, that's not gonna hit.
I don't take away anything.
This guy's stat block is basically the same because he's not fighting
you.
So I didn't think he would be a big deal.
So he has that's the reaction system.
He just take our love.
But yeah, but that's okay.
So our legendary actions work is like after a player ends its turn.
But if they're allied to the player, I don't think legendary actions apply.
Boo.
Boo what do you think?
Boo that's how the dragon's work.
I don't know.
Okay, what else can he do bonus?
No he can't do bonus.
He can do multi-attack so I'll try that.
I infest.
He feels again.
I tried.
Okay, don't fucking blame me.
Well, it's the monster's turn and it will
I thought the monster already worked.
I thought the monster slammed into me.
It's legendary actions.
He used just the other reactions.
He hasn't had his turn yet.
He will use multi-attack.
He will hit three times.
One, the two, whoever's closest.
He's going to hit this guy Ben and then
roll one D2.
Roll one D2.
Oh my god Ben might die.
Oh my god Ben is dead.
All right, let's see.
Attack.
We don't know.
He asked to actually swing.
Oh shit.
All right.
He quit.
No guys. Ben has a hundred and eight.
You see.
This guy is just walking up to Ben as he just
bites through his neck.
And the next attack will be
let me see.
The slam to throw Ben.
Okay, that does not hit.
And then he's going to attack with the tendrils to grapple Ben.
That does not hit.
Okay, Ben is not dead guys.
Very good.
So.
Look at the dude's lats.
Like come on now.
We can take bites.
Yeah, as you see, like the bite wound is kind of like rotting as it's just like kind of
burns away Ben's flesh as well.
All right, that's his turn.
As bad Daniel sees that he goes.
Fucking monster.
Okay, he's gonna.
He's gonna use his.
What do you call it?
What's the rogue thing?
Oh my god, I forgot the rogue thing.
No, what is it called?
The bonus thing.
Cunning action.
Sorry.
Oh, I love you.
He's gonna dash and he's gonna do his smoke kick.
Oh, that's a net 20 bro.
Daniel is on his game.
Oh my god.
Max damage too.
All right.
Uh, as he just smacks into the beast, you see like parts of its flesh automatically
lays coming up and closing.
Uh, now this is your turn.
All right.
Yeah, this is wrong.
You can transform.
I think you have more movement when you transform.
Yeah, but I can make it work.
I can make it anyway, but
Yeah, because you can use your like flurry.
What do you call it?
When step whatever for fuck it's called step of the winds or
take a vile.
That's what I'm saying.
You better pop that fucking vile.
Yeah, the wild is the wild is a bonus action.
Yeah, but same as this for me.
Yeah.
All right.
How did it all go?
Oh, you won transform.
Just do the transform thing.
I'll do the transformation.
Is that a form?
Is that an action or is that a bonus action?
That's more.
It's a bonus.
Yeah.
Oh, say less.
So I can fucking attack and then transform.
Oh, sorry.
I don't see anything anymore.
Wait, what?
Yeah.
Oh, this is because like the token thing.
Let me.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Next to start with nothing.
There you go.
Now you should be able to see this.
By the way, it's like completely dark
just so you know, because you guys can see it.
Because all of you have that question.
None of the NPCs can actually like make out anything.
It's just they're just going off of like noises and everything.
Also like this giant ball of fire.
My mouth is go ahead.
Thunder wave.
Go.
He succeeds.
Fuck.
But Thunder wave will go like straight, right?
Does it grow through enemies?
Yeah, but there's no one there.
It's Roma.
Oh, you want to go here this way?
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool.
So there's no.
Go ahead.
So is it half damage?
Yes.
Okay.
13, 6.
Yes.
There you go.
You see like the thunder still strikes him like a little
pieces of electricity as they spark off of your body.
Go into him.
But again, you see like the wounds are starting to close up already.
Okay, Roma's your turn.
All right.
Want to transform?
Yeah, let's go Hulk.
Let's go.
Let me do that for you.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, same thing happened.
My god.
Why does it do that?
Let me fix it.
Oh, I think I didn't ever do this for you because every time you were fighting in like
light.
So I never fixed this for you.
Okay, there you go.
All right.
So what's the
I got to remember what's that cold step thing where I can
freeze it.
I think it's
in your feet, which is called snow stump.
Be blinded for the end of the turn.
There's not probably any opportunity to act.
Yeah, let's fucking use that on him.
Okay, so how do you do it?
Shit.
I am
fuck.
Oh, whatever that was.
He's like, see, so he doesn't get blinded.
But you basically rush into him.
Like run into him trying to like push him
away as like this while the
like
bunch of snow just swirls around you.
But the
you see like that does not affect the monster at all.
I tried guys.
All right, you still have your
Oh, yeah, that is your action.
Sorry.
Oh, man.
Yeah, that was the action.
At the end of your turn,
you see the monster at this point.
It goes
and like let's out this like guttural scream.
As you start to see a bunch of
graves
being popped open as
shit.
Yeah.
The bug is coming.
The dead bodies rise from the graves.
Uh, and I'm going to add their initiative as 15.
Let me
add that here.
So the zombies will move at the initiative of 15
every time.
Yeah.
Huh.
It commandant.
The value 15.
There you go.
Uh, all right, Bob.
It's your turn.
That was his layer action.
Yeah.
I can do it again.
The flaming thing.
So you just move it again or what do you do?
It goes back and it's this matches against him.
Okay.
Do the thing again.
Just click on the thing so I can do the DC check.
All right.
Next save.
There we go.
He succeeds again.
Oh, we
do the damage.
All right.
Yes, zero to it.
Okay.
Five.
And where exactly are the undead that is here?
There you go.
Three are here.
One, two, three.
I probably should have like some ring around them
because you can't barely see them.
That makes more interesting.
All right, next is
Baptiste.
Do you have anything else Bob that you can do?
Oh no.
You have an action, right?
That was your bonus.
Yeah, yeah.
It's a Bob I think we can pretty hear you.
You're like very low volume.
I don't want to do the undead.
What?
Turn in dead.
I told you.
I only have one.
Okay, do it.
In one of the zombies.
Right.
I'm assuming this one straight ahead.
Of course it does.
Never mind then.
It saves the saving throw but you still damage, right?
No, it's no.
It does not damage at all if they save.
Yeah, because it's a catch up.
Oh, oh yeah, it is a henchrap yet, sir.
Baptiste, your turn.
Usefulness.
Give me one second.
Loading back.
There we go.
I am running.
Jumped right over to the other side of this guy.
Oh, not the axe.
Yeah, that's a thunderway, bro.
Thunderway doesn't.
Let me remove that then.
There you go.
He said I'm colliding with the wall.
Well, he's a big ass dude.
So I'm just gonna get to the other side of it.
But what do you want to do?
Just get to the other side to point with Ben.
Okay, so you want to jump around?
Who is he engaged with right now?
Probably a lot of people are surrounding him.
I'll say Roma is engaged with him right now,
so you should be able to like fly up and land on the other side.
There you go.
He just attacked Ben.
No, he attacked.
No, you just slammed into him right now.
Yeah.
I did.
While he was attacked with Ben.
Yeah, yeah.
Because he just attacked Ben.
So like, I'm just, I was running up trying to do something
and I just fell off his ass.
All right, Baptiste, what you're doing?
Wanging.
That is.
16-metre head.
Again, it's like just flesh.
There's no like armor really.
St. Latch.
Swing it.
Oh my god.
16-16-17.
And 15, all of them hit.
Do the damage.
Wait, did I roll price on that today?
No, the 17 was the damage to that.
Okay, okay, okay.
There you go.
You see you, as soon as you touch him,
the impact of your punches, you can already feel
is a bit different.
It's like a question stopping your punches.
As the punch basically touches it,
and as soon as you like lifted, it just closes back up.
The second one, 14 damage.
All right, there you go.
Jesus Christ, this dude has a lot of health.
Fuck.
May need to.
Do you want to do again?
No, because I'd have to use a flurry to find the way.
Okay, so you do it too, right?
Nevermind.
Yeah.
What are you doing, bonus?
The other arm straight with my bonus.
So I'm done.
Yeah, you're done.
All right, it's Ben's turn.
He's going to growl and try to hit the ping again
because he is at this point, pretty much pissed.
I infest.
Jesus Christ.
Come on now.
Let's go.
At least hit twice.
Yeah, yeah, I did.
Hit twice.
He did.
Normal.
Again, the same thing happens as soon as you see
like the iron fist land on the
the creature's body, it kind of like bounces back at Ben again.
There you go.
Next is the zombies churn.
Zombie will try to move an attack
to the closest person they are.
Where are the zombies?
Okay.
Yeah.
There you go.
I see them now.
They're final size.
This one will move here.
This one will go to Daniel.
Yeah.
I'm going to slam into all three of you.
The first one is from Bob.
Sorry, Roma.
The second one is for Ben.
The third one is for Daniel.
Okay, I have a question for you.
Yeah, the first one succeeds.
Roll.
Oh, no, the first one will hit, right?
22.
Hey, well, if it's for me, wouldn't it be since I'm raging?
Wouldn't it be with disadvantage?
Since it's a strength.
No, you did reckless like that's.
No, last turn I didn't do reckless.
Last turn I do.
I didn't do.
But it I don't think rage automatically has like some disadvantage or anything.
I don't know how that works.
If you do reckless, then the other person also has
advantage on you, but that's about it.
I don't get rage adds anything other than that.
Okay, 22 will hit.
This is your damage, Roma.
Three, which is two.
Yeah, just have.
And then roll double damage for Ben.
Oh, Ben.
And then always the last hit.
I think the last one mystery.
Oh, yeah, it didn't miss.
Okay, this one tries to flail at like Daniel, but he just dodges him.
Next, it's going to be the creature.
You see the creature.
Will.
Put a bunch of it tendrils in the ground as he does that.
I'm going to regain some of its HP.
There you go.
And.
Then it's like this thing at first.
Gonna go into barbaric fury.
And everyone within 10 feet will take three amounts of necrotate damage.
That's all of us.
Which is 2d6, honestly, except for Bob.
Yeah.
Everyone.
It's like running was the bright idea of throw.
Three.
The fucking crow, man.
I need to turn that off.
All right, everyone took their damages.
All right, next.
It's.
Yeah, I think that's his action and bonus.
Yeah, yeah, all right, let's move on.
Daniel.
Yeah.
It's going to.
Multi-attack.
Hard strike twice.
Normal.
One to the zombie and if the zombie dies, it will switch the attack to this guy.
Mama, mama, mama 11 with it.
Not killed the zombie.
Jesus Christ.
The zombies are buffed.
And the other one also goes to the zombie then.
21 hits.
Let me roll damage.
This one can do not be.
All right, you see Daniel just
bash the zombies,
sculling with both of his fists just boom.
And it's going to be your turn, Malthus.
All right.
Uh, both are one of those vials.
Yeah, let me take the next three attacks,
skill checks or spell casting rule that use the charge object,
which is your, if you laced your hands with those,
then that's going to do 1d plus damage.
All right.
Uh, first one.
That hits.
Let's go.
That match.
Uh, plus another D4.
Yeah.
A seven.
Okay.
First, the 11 and total.
Right.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Uh, yeah, let's.
Completely.
No, wait a minute.
No, I can't.
I can't.
Here's the ball.
Hit me.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's your turn.
Do you want to do something?
Yes.
Oh, yeah, that you already used their bonus.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, all right.
At the end of your turn, this creature will make
his other religion reaction, which is writing Paul.
He grabs one creature in 10 feet radius.
So everyone make, uh,
strength save to see which one he grabs.
Is it a grapple save?
Yes.
Strength save.
All right.
Well, not a super grapple.
You get out of the grapple that is not the tender does not get to you.
Roma, you might.
You might get hit.
Baptist, can you do another strength save?
Yeah, I got you.
It's your mom because you're going to be escaping grapple.
Yeah.
Daniel will succeed.
Ben will not succeed, but Ben's the lowest.
So he will try to pull Ben.
Let me roll for.
To the six.
Did I succeed?
Yes.
You didn't succeed, but it's only going to grapple one creature.
So it's going to be Ben and Ben takes seven months of damage.
Just 16.
See?
I hope so.
Yeah.
All right.
Next is Roma.
It's your turn.
And I'm swiping at him.
Swipe swipe.
Go ahead.
Regular tech and then the boneness.
Let's.
Okay.
Like why.
All right.
Come on.
You know, do you want to do reckless or anything or no?
I don't think I can in my beast form.
No, no, you should.
Barbarian.
No, I'm just going to just go ahead.
You should have advantage.
You should have advantage regardless.
You're flanking him.
So that's the first one.
That hits on there.
That'll be the second one.
That does not hit somehow.
Do the damage for the first one.
What is it again?
Again, Roma, you also feel the same kind of like as you plunge into it's like rotting body.
There is no almost no
non-feedback.
Like you seem like you feel like you like punching into like a question.
Okay, that's your turn, right?
Okay, Bob, it's your turn.
Okay, I need to get closer to the zombies.
But yeah, the far ball means everything goes again and then I go
what was it that Dex saved?
Yeah, Dex saved 13.
It succeeds.
Yeah.
He literally has critically succeeded every saving throw.
It's crazy.
Not possible.
And since our
never mind.
What's the three?
Roma, since I'm getting closer.
How did I target myself?
Just do mirror match.
I'll target you.
Okay.
I think it's applied.
I don't think you need to do anything with that.
Okay.
All right, that's your bonus.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry, the movement was your bonus and this is your action, right?
Same here with bonus.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Roma, you can right now see the remote that
how low dropped as he was getting murdered.
Oh, I thought that I thought that one in the black hole.
I'm sorry.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I would have made that up.
That didn't go in the mo.
That cold.
But do you see the remote?
It's not turned on or anything.
It's just laying there.
Baptiste is your turn.
After crunching and sleep that my
fists of different mass.
We're flaming.
He said flame on.
Okay, for the next 10 rounds,
you will have this mode on while in flame on mode.
You should bright light and 10 foot radius.
Demlight for another 10 feet.
Once per turn, you deal with melee attack
and you didn't well before fire damage.
Cool.
Go ahead.
All right.
So he's getting hit with fire damage and lost damage at the same time.
It's not Pokemon, all right?
It's not going to do anything.
13 hit.
13 does not hit.
That's what it turns.
Because flame was a bonus.
Yeah, as your flame fist tries to grab him,
he grabs your fist with one of his arms.
He like lets out this like God roll scream right at your face.
I'll spit in him now for his famous.
I knew you were on that freak shit.
Ben is grappled at this point.
So he'll try to get out of it with the insurance check.
Okay, he's out.
All right.
And then,
can he, is that an action?
I think that's an action.
So he can't do anything.
Okay.
Next is the zombies.
About me, about Ben.
Again, try to slam into you.
Normal.
Then normal.
There's only two.
One's dead.
Oh yeah, one is dead.
Okay, so the first one hits, right?
15?
Yeah, that hit.
Yep.
I'll do the damage for that.
As the zombies still trying to like
chow down on you, roba.
It kind of bites in into your fur.
The second zombie won't be affecting Ben at all.
It's just trying to like claw through his fists.
Next is the beast again.
He will do multi attack.
First of all, he'll heal.
Sorry.
Just.
Go.
He's crying.
And then he'll multi attack.
Bite someone.
Throw the tendrils.
And then slam.
Okay, let me roll who he hits.
1D.
1, 2, 3, 4, right?
Daniel is a bit far, so he won't attack him probably.
1D 4.
I'm starting at Ben and then going anti-clockwise.
Roll 1D 4.
So it hits roba, then it will hit mouthless and then it will hit roba again.
So 21 hits.
Bite.
Jesus.
Okay.
He will try to bite into you as you see like part of your fur
trying to starting to dissolve as like the strange green goo
out of his mouth is affecting effectively like acid burning your fur.
The second hit was mouthless rain.
Okay, can you make a strength save for me, Meltus?
Oh, sorry, I didn't need to roll that.
Tendrils was 12.
12 does not hit, right?
Nope.
Okay, now mine then.
He's going to slam into you again, Roma.
Strength save, right?
Yeah.
You fail the strength save as well.
He slams into you as you fall prone.
That will just remove like half your movement, that's it.
Next turn.
Next is Daniel and he will try to smoke kick him again.
And again.
No, only one hits.
And again, it's like some kind of like whatever body is comprised of,
it's very like compressive and it just repels everything that's attacking him.
So as you see like Daniel's fist land, like legs land on him,
he just bounces back and falls back to his own place,
whatever he started from.
Meltus, your turn.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We're also flame on.
All right, let's go.
Both of them are going to start flame on.
[LAUGH]
Don't forget to add your 1D4 Lightning damage to every Lightning attack you do.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, just general attack for it.
No, no, only Lightning attack increases the hits of Lightning attacks.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So you're having a way to mean electric burns.
Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
1D4 fire, 1D4 Lightning and whatever your attack is basically that.
So but that's your bonus already so you can only attack once anyway.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Nope, that's it.
We'll look at it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, that will not hit.
As the monster screams again at the end of your turn, he will raise more zombies.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Stop that.
[LAUGH]
At this point, she will probably raise someone from this grave.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Here, and this grave here, and this grave here.
There you go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, that's the end of your turn.
Roma, it's your turn.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, I'm on the ground.
I see that remote next to me.
I'm just going to grab it and see if there's any like indications on it.
That says like destroy, kill, whatever.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There's nothing on the remote.
Just a close capsule on top of it.
If you flip the capsule open, there's just a red button.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's yeah, it's probably due to donate via use for.
Hi.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right.
I'll say grab is like a free action so you can still do your bonus end of it.
So.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, I'm going to have to stand up.
And then bonus action, I'm just going to swipe at the zombie behind me.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Bronn just removes like half your movement.
So it does not affect the action or anything.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, so that yeah, I'm going to swipe, swipe.
All right.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Swipe, swipe, swipe.
Well, I'm going once for the zombie next to me.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now, behind me, and if I can kill him, then I'm going to go after the big guy.
If not, I'm going to swipe at the zombie.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That will hit.
Okay, so let's roll the damage on that one.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, that's not going to kill him.
So then let's do a normal attack.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That does it.
And the damage on that one.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You're still getting the zombie, right?
Yeah, cuz I'm going to kill that little thing.
Okay, that zombie on the second hit, you just crash into like whatever like
layers of flesh it still had on as its body collapses on the ground.
And this one will die.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Next, it's going to be Bob.
There's one zombie here, there's a zombie here, where's a zombie here?
One zombie here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so, uh, manually, waiting to hear turn.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'll do the deck save.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
He saves again.
One less than critical is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, there we go.
Thanks to damages.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You're not having a tax bills that do, uh,
Yeah, there's a good picture.
I have literally zero a tax bill.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We're going to run right into a zombie that way.
You got three of them.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You may need to change the spells.
We'll talk about it later.
You're telling me, right?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You're right, you're right, you're right behind a zombie.
It's going to be a training arc for just Bob for next season.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You're doing nothing.
I don't know if you're that kind of.
Uh, well, what?
It's going to attack you, Bob, if you run past a zombie.
That could obtain you ran right past two zombies.
Each get a attack of opportunity, bro.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
He literally passed right past it.
Yeah, that's right here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Here.
Okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
What?
Sorry.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah.
Do you want?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Do you want to just take the damage and do the burning hands anyway?
What?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, it never mind.
Yeah, I take it, I take it, I take it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, it's going to try to slam into you as you run past it.
Yeah, it doesn't.
Okay, cool.
Uh, do the burning hands on these two, right?
Let me check.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh, sorry.
Dexave.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Normal.
Oh, it feels.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's go, both of them fail, do the damage.
All right, both of those zombies start to burn and as they're clothes catching fire and
the rotting flesh that they have on their body, just start scatching on fire.
As basically Bob opens up like one of his arm and just like a flame thrower comes out of it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, first thing is come or they're.
That's easier turn.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Give me one second, it just locked me out.
This is fucking, this is dope.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So we have fire eyes like Nink.
Fire again.
It's just that elemental mishmash and soon enough Bob will join in and it will be in a Karate 2.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Are you saying hitting the toe of the dead?
And you failed to say first.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I mean, it is rolling, that 20s and 19s.
Yeah, that is crazy.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That was not it.
One more time.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Never the head.
Do the damage and do 1D4.
Fire.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Gotcha.
Why did it take me a little to the top?
There we go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Normal dormant.
And then 1D4.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Again, you punch into him as like the flames from your back, like surround your arm as the flame
just impacts him at the end, like a little burst of flame.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The three flame damage.
There you go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Next is Ben.
He's going to again.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I infest break or slam.
My god Ben, come on, it's better.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I don't know what happens to, and
we see this as soon as this watch.
At least that's good, that's good.
And as Ben just takes both of his fists and just slimes into the head of this monster.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now the screams.
It's his turn now.
And it's going to do it again with the multi-attack.
Plus heal.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Which is 15.
So basically what Ben did didn't matter.
[LAUGH]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Good job, Ben.
We don't hurt you, Ben.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let me do the attack.
Right.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It will definitely fail whoever he hits.
Seven will also probably fail.
We'll see who 21 heads.
One, the five.
I'm going to put him here somewhere.
I'll say at this point he will be close enough.
It's going to hit Ben.
Bro, Ben is getting the shard and it'll just take every time.
That's fine.
Oh shit.
Five will be Daniel.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Which is also fine.
The die is fine.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Why did I roll again?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Two times Ben and.
Okay, yeah, Ben dies, I guess.
What was the one?
>> No. >> No, no, no.
>> No, no, no.
>> I'm joking, I'm joking.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But the last one hits that will hit Ben.
And six damage.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The monster sends it off with him.
The scream.
All right, Daniel's turn.
He will do two hard strikes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
16 hits.
17 hits.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> He got you there.
All right, let's go.
Let's go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Nexus Malthus.
[LAUGH]
It does not hit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Malthus being.
>> No disadvantage.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, it's 19 plus, because I didn't know it was a disadvantage.
Okay, 19 will hit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I mean, both will hit, I think, yeah, both will hit.
Okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And then lightning.
One before lightning.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, because my-
Did it run out?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, I don't do lightning damage to my talents.
No, the talents don't do lightning.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There we go.
30.
Do your attack again?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That will hit.
>> All your talents just overcome magical resistance, okay?
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
17.
All right, there we go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
As at this point, the body of this creature's losing its hold.
Like whatever was keeping it together, you'd see the tendrils that were like,
he threw into the ground, basically the tendrils that are going into the ground.
They're trying to, they're starting to like lose grip and it's starting to come out of the ground.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, it's a Roman's turn.
Sorry, at the end of your turn, Malthus, it's going to do its legendary action and.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Riding pole.
There you go.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Normal.
Can you all make a, it's trans safe.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So one, one grapple creature.
Yes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I think I'm safe.
[LAUGH]
Yeah.
Let me.
Hopefully it's been again, shit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
God, it ain't been.
[LAUGH]
It's someone.
It's Daniel.
[LAUGH]
[LAUGH] All right, so as the creature pulls on him, he becomes grappled and he will take
2D6.
A chronic damage.
I think Daniel has not gotten hit anyway that much so it'll be able to take it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
There you go.
Yeah, Roma, it's your turn.
Okay, so am I technically flanking him?
So it's just-
Where the fuck are the zombies?
I can't, I can't.
I can't see them in.
I missed the zombies, sorry.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Too late.
They still feel.
No.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, they're not dead.
This one will move to him.
This one will turn towards you.
This one will turn towards Bob and they will start attacking.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Slam.
Malfus, let me know if that has, that's not it, that's not one.
[LAUGH]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Seven does not head him and Bob, let me know if this hits.
Does not head, okay, so it didn't matter, fuck me.
[LAUGH]
They burned alive.
Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, Roma, go ahead.
All right, so, so he's attacking fucking Daniel, so I can get advantage because of the
plank, right?
Yes.
Yeah, also think of it means I don't like it.
Yeah, yeah.
So I'm going to try to attack the remaining tendrils that are in the ground.
And then.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, you want to, you want to stop the whatever's like,
pumping through the, yeah, yeah, okay, go ahead.
Yep, so I'm going to swipe and if I break, break it on the first one,
I'm going to use my second swipe to go for his back or some sort of.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, does not head.
You try to swipe it, but the, the, the, the,
thickness of the tendrils there's too much right now.
That will hit.
Okay.
Damage.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
13.
13 will completely, cleanly cut off one of the tendrils.
You're still one pumping something into the Screacher's body.
That will not damage its main body, by the way.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's not what I was just trying to fucking make it so it doesn't keep fucking healing it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anything else you want to do or that's it.
That's all I can do.
No, Bob, sir turn.
You want to do the obligatory fire damage?
Yes, yes, okay.
He fails for the first fucking time.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Take that eight and be happy with it.
Well, you're not going to be happy with it.
He's going to be mad about it.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Like this.
Hey, yeah, my friends see which ones are dead and which ones are alive because I think
Dyson or where that is.
This one is then, this one is dead.
All of what you can see are alive.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Try to do that.
Another burning hands for these two.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Click on burning hands.
It's still I need you to use the spell slot.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, just do the damage.
Yes, another, okay.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
First one feels the second one succeeds, but the first one will take full damage and the second one will take half.
Yeah, okay, any of them died?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Nope, both of them still alive.
You don't have that arm for now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, next.
Nexus Baptist, your turn.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Why am I sideways like this?
What happened?
I don't know, it's you, man.
You're controlling him.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now fix to you.
Thank you.
All right.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Oh yeah.
Are you gonna grab it to a punch?
Grab it to punch?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Until the end of your turn, your arms are like steel.
One before four is obviously adding four is damaged.
All right, if you hit the target, you must succeed on your strength save or we push 10 feet.
All right, I'll do a strength save.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I haven't swung it.
I need to make the.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He'll succeed this strength save doesn't get.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We have to make it each time I hit and I'm doing 30 of blows.
All right.
That's one.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
Bad does not hit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's do another strength save.
I'll do another strength save.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
How many users do you have on grab it or punch?
I think only two.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Yeah, it's only two, but it lasts the whole turn and I didn't land a single hit
anyway, so the strength save support is.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right.
Well.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
That's your turn.
Yeah, that is my turn quite literally.
All right, next is.
Ben.
Ben will do one, I'm fist and one break through slam.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
26 does head.
One of them head usually.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Wait, doesn't Ben have advantage?
Yes.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I don't know, you know what, sure.
Why not?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
At least, yeah.
Okay, yeah, both of them head.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
He's gonna break this bitch.
Let me do the damage.
There we go.
One.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's shit, bro.
One is twenty.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The first one.
Well, quite literally, just just.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I think that will kill him.
Yeah, that kills him.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
You see, Ben?
What?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
If I would have landed one punch, I could have.
Yeah, you could have killed him.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
As Ben just slams into it, you see like both of the parts of the body,
like the human, the man and the woman part, he just prize it open with the second head.
As the body, the amalgamations body just falls flat down as blood pulls out.
And the tendril comes out on its own and that said all of the zombies,
that were surrounding it, also fall down.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Wow, and the zombies just disintegrate like fuck, let's go.
I would have captured on the back of Ben was moving in a part to act like I got the last hit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, there that is, and at this point, you see almost all of you have made it not that bad, honestly.
No, we only damned it to what the three damage will do, that's what they charge.
Yeah.
It just, I think it was just a lot of health and everything.
It didn't get to do much.
Yeah, it also focused solely on Ben, who has probably the most HB.
Out of him and all of the NPCs.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
No, because I was seeing that damage.
I was like, I would have got insta killed if he hit me.
Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And that's with my freaking half damage.
Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Well, you got lucky if you didn't accept like, let them go, it would have gone away different.
I'm gonna power down, I'm gonna be D-transform.
>> All right, you D-transform.
Do you want to D-transform to Malthus?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
How good?
>> Hey, yeah.
>> You want D-transform?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
As like both of them D-transform some smoke comes out of their body as
both of you just kind of get down on your knees, kind of exhausted from the fight.
Daniel and Ben also hunkered down as Daniel checks in on like how wounded Ben is.
Well, he's taking care of that Bob, you can move in maybe.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm gonna.
>> I mean.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> There was another zombie here, I forgot.
Okay, well, he's done.
>> I thought he was never dead.
>> Yeah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> All right guys, are we inviting him with us?
>> I don't know.
>> We'll just take him to the next island.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Come on guys, come on, we can at least take him to the next island.
Cuz we're, I'm gonna blow this one up.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, what do you want, guys, what to do?
>> I don't believe they want to come with us, especially if we have Will and
Sarah.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> But they might not want to, but like, I'm literally gonna blow this place up.
And then I'm gonna show them the fucking like flip dial with the execution button.
I'm just gonna hold it up just out and reach a map tease.
So if he tries to reach for it, I'm just gonna put it in my pocket.
I'm gonna be like, I'm gonna blow this bitch up.
Like, I'm pretty sure they have their own means of leaving the island right now.
Gonna ask Daniel, you have your own two out.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> What?
>> Gonna go to Daniel and ask him, like, do you have your own chef out of here?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Well, this is the first time I've come to this place, but
I think if you had this way, we should be able to get out, it points to the gate of the graveyard.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So you have your means of escaping the islands?
>> Oh, you mean us?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Yeah, we do have our ship.
It's hunker down to one of the other ports.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> And I'm ready of El.
>> What?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I'm ready of Will.
>> Yeah, yeah, you can already will.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Did you find anyone?
>> Yeah, there were some kids, some, well, there was a lot of panic around here.
I think it's good that we came to check it out.
We got everyone off some robots that we could find in surrounding
merchant ships that were docked here.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So they should be able to make it back to the closest island, hopefully.
The grandline, you know, you never know.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Did you find any, the boss?
>> What?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Any valuables, things and notes.
>> No, I was, I was trying to save people that, dude.
Come on.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I know you were trying to save people, but things can always catch your eye even in the midst of a
pretty important goal.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> We wait the time.
We gotta get to the ship, bro.
>> Speaking of the ship.
>> The ship.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's not here.
>> What do you mean it's not here?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Roma, did you tie the ship down?
>> No, we literally pulled up to the area.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
They tied it down for us.
Remember, we had to jump off the ship.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I'm the chef, I ain't no duck worker.
>> No, I did, I do remember Sarah could telling me that she did tie it down.
It's not even that I asked some kids about it and they saw the anchor getting out of the
water and the ship just moved away.
They did not see anyone on the ship.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> It was probably the kid.
The kids you broke the bell kind of saved Roma.
>> So they stole our ship.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Is there another ship here?
>> The kids told me that the ship just left.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> How long did I do it?
>> I don't know, maybe.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
I actually don't know.
The kids just said, we just saw the ship go away.
When I asked where the ship was, the nearest kid I could find.
Because there were all just kids there, then the guys were supposed to be on the island.
So it was supposed to save these kids off the island and nowhere here.
Okay, I'm getting pissed off.
Anyway, the kid, I don't know what his name is, but the kid said that the anchor just
started to go up and soon after the ship left.
So he assumed that there was someone on the ship.
>> So all of our stuff is going now.
>> Yes, that's what I'm trying to say.
And we had a lot of important stuff, by the way.
>> I know there was a journal I was trying to move.
>> Forget about the journal, you guys went through all of this trouble to get that ship.
>> We did indeed.
And the ship just gets up and goes like, so we're going to have to ride with these fox
to the next island to get another ship.
God damn.
>> Anyway, just try to find your way back here.
Did you?
>> We're commenting on their ship.
>> Take care of that.
Who ship?
What are you talking about?
>> He's talking about taking spite in that ship.
Yep.
>> Oh, okay.
Do you want me to track it down?
>> Please do.
>> Okay, do you know any exact location where it is?
Daniel, where was your ship located?
>> Wait.
>> Can you make a deception check?
>> What?
>> I think we're on the same thing.
We're going to ride with him on their ship.
Not just take their ship and leave them.
>> Yeah, we're going to ride with him.
Like if our ship is gone, we're just going to be like,
all right, we already fucked you guys up twice now.
We're not going to do this again.
You're just going to come with us on your ship.
You're going to take us to the next island.
We're going to get off.
Like.
Or we can check out.
How are we going to track down our ship?
The kids literally just said the anchor went up by itself
and it left by itself.
There was nobody on the ship.
>> They know a direction.
>> So what I'm saying though is they tell us the direction.
We have the spider crew take us in that direction.
>> Yes.
Like.
>> All right.
>> We go and get our ship.
And as we're riding away, I'm going to flip the top,
hit that button and watch the island explode.
>> Okay. So are you guys headed up to the docks?
>> Can we go to mutant industries, the main building,
and try to search for any valuable spurs?
>> I mean, you can bet first search on whatever's on Halibut.
>> How does that say?
>> It's on the black hole.
>> He got his head.
>> He just pulled.
>> That's it.
The back hole is.
>> Okay.
>> Well, yeah, it's true.
>> Let's search his body.
That's what I'm going to do.
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> I'm all up in them guts.
>> Can you do investigation?
I just want to check what you find.
>> That ban is wrong.
>> I'll say if you are all looking for it,
just do with advantage.
>> Oh god, Damon, I just did normal.
Bob broke with that ban.
>> All right.
>> So just roll with it.
>> Whatever, 13 is good enough.
You should be able to find like a small key in one of his pockets.
>> The Babtees here.
>> Whoever wants to have it, I'll drop it in there.
>> I'll take the key of her.
>> Yeah, you don't.
>> You told him he got no money.
He got nothing else on him.
Just a key.
>> People don't carry money on their inner pockets.
>> What would he about people carry money all the time?
They got, they got like a dollar too.
>> Sorry.
>> He was literally wanting to die, so I don't, I don't have money.
>> It's just what was in his jacket.
>> All right, Babtees, can you accept the thing?
>> I don't accept it.
>> Why is it not valid?
Sorry.
Then to player, Babtees, one, send item.
Okay, it's not going for some reason.
I'll just drop it for you.
All right, there you go.
You should have that in your inventory.
How does office keep?
Okay.
>> Let's go.
>> Where do you want to keep going?
Ben is going to,
>> I'm going to either find Hall of Office or the Mugan Industries
main building to find valuables to help
Babtees prove his use.
>> I will.
>> You will be able to go toward any
vehicle want to.
Meanwhile, Daniel will say something to Ben.
Malthus, you're close enough, you should be able to hear it.
As he says, I think we should take care of that thing.
Daniel claps his hand and just like a bunch of
like charcoal drops out of his hand as he forms like a circle around this creature.
Ben just walks up to it and lights a fire
through one of its like-
>> Before you do that, before you do that,
hey, I got to get a piece of that technical thing because we have somebody that's
suffering from something that this regenerative properties might be able to help them.
>> Okay, you take.
>> Can you do an investigation again, Roma?
>> After you do an investigation, do a nature as well.
>> Oh, shit.
>> You try to cut one of the tendrils as one of them is just
falls off. It doesn't, you know, stay intact.
You can try with like three more if you want to do that.
>> Can I just, I gotta keep you said just three more nature checks?
>> Yes. Just to see if you can carve it out properly before like them disintegrating.
With the first investigation, you can't really look for anything else that you can salvage.
Okay, from the first nature check, you should be able to gather one of the tendrils.
For the second nature check, I say you can get another tendril, but you also see like the
body, like the outer body of this creature has formed like some kind of like fiber layer,
and this might be useful in creating like armor.
>> Something like that. >> Yeah, I'm gonna take that.
>> In your misc thing, just add two things.
>> Okay. >> I'll add it, I'll add it.
>> Ten drills, two, ten drills, two, album, fiber.
>> We can't talk to Linus, can we?
>> No, you don't have any weight of communicating with what it does.
>> Okay, so I could tell whale that we got some of this tendril for Sathlia.
>> Mm-hm.
>> You could do that. >> Like to see if that will.
>> Okay, Daniel looks at you as he goes.
Is that enough?
>> Yeah, that's enough.
>> All right, let it up, Ben.
Ben just lights up like lighter and just throws it into the
core as the body of this creature starts to burn.
And soon enough it will just form ashes.
Do you want to throw a halo in there?
>> Hell yeah. >> All right.
Get rid of the bodies. >> Hang up.
>> No proof, it's not like this island is going to implode in a few hours.
>> Yeah, is it?
>> You're forgetting that I'm holding the fucking detonator like.
>> Yeah. >> I can't wait to hit that button.
>> All right, so at this point I'll say Melphus and whoever's leaving with,
sorry, Melphus none, Baptiste.
Who's leaving with Baptiste while this is happening?
>> I'll join him.
>> I was taking Bob with me because I'm doing this poor Bob.
>> Bob, I'll go with, I'm going to go to the ship.
>> All right, so I'll say Daniel and Roma and Ben will go this way and you three will go that way,
okay?
As you guys move ahead, let me move you guys back to
>> Where is it?
>> No, no.
>> Her poop there, there you go.
>> You guys are back here.
Roma, you're on literally the other side of the island.
>> But I'm meeting up with Well and Circa because they are going to the docks.
>> Yeah, but they're on the other side of the docks.
I said like there were multiple docks on this area.
So the earlier docks that you saw is probably not where Daniel and the rest part.
>> Well, I'd be following them because I have to go to their ship.
So I'd be going where they think their ship's going.
>> Yeah, exactly.
So right now these guys will head into like the mean.
So do you want to head first into the mean office?
Or do you want to go into any of the other buildings?
>> We'll go into the buildings and end off at the main.
>> Okay.
You go into Hallows office, you use the key to get inside.
Most of what you see is just shift timings of different people and the cost values and stuff
like that. You also see like small receipts made to like grave diggers and stuff like that
on the side.
One of the skills and remains that he was pumping into the machine because he didn't want to
feed actual people to the machine anymore.
>> I would like to take all that to give to a reporter later to make an article about this.
>> Okay, where would you find a reporter?
>> On somewhere.
>> Okay. If the can you give me a.
>> Investigation. I guess all the few would be looking for something valuable around.
>> Bob, check with that vanit because we're helping you.
>> And Bob has a super goggles.
>> That he didn't use.
>> I mean, we can't use.
>> Mostly. Okay, Bob looks around. Bob, you find a.
>> Okay.
>> You find a small like ball which is like glowing with the same kind of energy,
like blue energy going through it. You think you can maybe utilize it in one of your
body parts or like one of your energy cores. You can maybe slot that in somewhere to make use of it later.
And you guys find 200,000 bellies in one of the chests in his office,
Hallows office.
>> Gold players killing. I'm just kidding.
>> Who's going to keep the 200,000?
>> I'll keep it.
>> Will you give that over to Baptiste Bob?
>> Hold on, Bob, Bob keep it. That's shit.
>> I was thinking, I'll keep it.
>> T.A. You can even get a tell anybody.
>> He doesn't even realize it's muted.
>> Oh, yeah. I was.
Yeah, what I was saying is I literally don't have this friend to carry that much money.
>> I mean, it's fine. I don't think Bob probably wouldn't be that much.
I remember, I think Lufus carried like 200 million in like a suitcase.
This is my suitcase. I don't think it matters. Okay,
add that much to your inventory, Baptiste.
Oh, Bagel Bellies. Okay, there you go. All right. Do you want to go into any of the other buildings?
>> Yep, next building.
>> Which one? Which one? Point at it.
You're right now inside this one. Where do you want to go?
Inside butch one. Where are you pointing?
>> I'm still at the graveyard. Oh, sorry.
I was like, bro, what is happening? It should be able to see that.
>> Okay, which one did we just come out of?
>> This one.
>> Is this one right here?
>> This one is just like a big building with like tubes coming out where like smokes coming out.
Chimney is a big, huge chimney. Nothing much.
What about what?
>> Here.
>> It's just a dock. It's just normal dock.
>> I don't know. Here.
>> No, just the building. Just point at the building.
I will take your bit of time to go around and get inside it.
Are you sure you have time?
>> Yes. This is the first time the work has been interrupted. Someone would be coming here soon.
Okay. Are you going to get in?
>> Go around inside this building. You see a door just completely shut off.
What do you want to do?
>> Try to open it.
>> Okay. Can you give me an investigation?
>> It's just being --
>> Coming on.
>> Bob, open this door.
>> Bob, if it's an ad, it's normal.
>> It's a small slot for some form of card.
Like an ID card to maybe get in.
>> You get in, like, is there a swipe or swipe or something on the door?
What?
>> I get it. What did I get?
>> You didn't get anything to swipe. I'm just saying there's like a door which has like something to
slot something in like a card or something to get inside.
>> Doesn't mouthless have a key? Who has the key?
>> He has a key. He has a key. There's no ID card.
It's going to be seen in all the rest of the buildings.
There is no windows, not really.
>> I'm breaking down the door.
>> Okay, you can try.
Do it with advantage or whatever.
All that matters is --
Yeah, all that matters is the damage.
>> Nope. That is not enough.
>> I'll hit it again.
>> You can't hit it again. It's just -- you know, it's one strike.
If you can't break it down, you can't break it down.
>> You keep trying until you succeed, okay?
>> No, no. I don't think that's how it works.
>> But you have the fucking plus 10 strike, all right?
I'm not going to give you that.
Is this a building over here?
>> Yeah, all of these buildings will have some kind of identity that you have to provide to pass
through. The rest of the buildings are open because of the people left, because the way outside
is mostly open. But --
>> We can go there. Okay.
The way outside is open, but all the buildings shut down as soon as like the alarm bells
went off. And hello probably shut down all the buildings once that happened.
>> That's all the buildings.
>> So none of these buildings are created.
>> Yeah.
>> We'll go back to Hallows office and see if we can find an ID card.
>> All right.
I mean, you already did investigate it. You won't probably find it again.
>> All right. Do we switch to --
>> Wait, did you say this was a building down here?
>> Yeah, again, it was all closed. All of them are closed now.
>> Well, since it's a different door, can I try breaking that door down?
>> I'm going to stay here just to break doors down. You can try.
>> Wait.
>> I'll give it that. Sure. Just do the down.
>> It's the main building. I have to try to get into the main.
>> All right.
>> The main is probably where Hallows is. Like the construction, like what do you mean?
Mean Wayne. For 15, it's not going to break it.
Well.
All right.
>> Just leave the door open.
>> Do we give up or no?
>> I'm going back to investigate Hallows' body for a key card.
>> You're going back to the burned body that your mom fucking burned.
>> That body's shard. Any key card that's gone.
>> It's gone.
>> We're done.
>> Yeah, yeah. We gotta get on the ship and get out.
>> All this shit up.
>> All right. Roma, you see Daniel and,
what do you call it? Can Ben with you making toward another doc for Calisto?
This dog just basically leads back up to the same place, but it's just on the opposite side of
the island. So while you are waiting there, Will quickly comes in as he probably saw you,
somewhere while he was patrolling the area and he meets up with you with Serika and Chloe.
He dumps them off. I'm going to do a con save for Chloe.
Okay.
As he dumps Chloe off, Serika at this point is pretty used to it.
So she does not really care, but Chloe would just walks up to Daniel as she just throws up on him.
And yeah, it goes, I don't ever let me go with the,
and Daniel just look at the moment on his body.
So I'm assuming soon after you guys can make it toward them.
On the other side, maybe Will contacts you and gives you the information where the other dogs are.
Yeah. How long are they away from us?
Probably 10, 20 minutes because it would take you the same amount of time to get there
for them to get here. Okay. Why?
Because it feels 30 minutes, I was just going to do a, like what the fuck is that?
Small, like a short rest.
But short rest is an hour.
I was hoping it was going to be a lot longer for you guys to start to have the building.
Yeah. No, no, I should be enough.
Like the jitter is walking around, I guess.
All right, so I'll say at this point you guys make it to the other side of
Colisto to the other dogs. And do you see that?
We get back and that he's looks visibly annoyed.
Well, Daniel goes,
I hope he'll meet again if you're still breathing out to this.
What are you talking about, bro? We already hashed this out.
You're taking us to our boat. Our boat somehow mysteriously floated away.
Some kids said, well, which direction did they say?
It went the same direction that the basically Daniel's boat is basically, let's say a few came
from here, right? You remember where your originally came from, right?
Yeah, down there.
So you basically went here and then went around.
So it would go exactly where Daniel and everyone, the spider ship is parked.
Sorry, our boat's right there.
No, it's our boat's right there.
Went that direction. You don't know your boats right there or not.
But if we're with Daniel's boat,
like, and you said it went the direction of Daniel's boat.
Direction. So it went north. That's what I'm saying.
Okay. Okay. So anyway, anyway, we were told our boat went north.
So you're going to take us north and tell the next island.
We'll get to that next island. We'll leave you guys alone.
Like we already hashed this out.
Like we're with you. You're with us till the next island.
So let's load up on as much supplies as we can for all of us to fit on your boat to the next island.
North. We are.
We're not locked without a part.
So unless you have one.
I so unless you got it. Yeah, unless you got another boat or you know where our boat went.
Like you're with us till the next island.
And we have to head north.
Also, we kind of saved your life, you know, several times.
All right.
Can you guys do a persuasion with a new anage?
Who has the highest charisma?
Unfortunately, Roman was only one talking.
So I kind of have to be here.
16.
Are we about to have to fight for this boat?
Because our next option is unfortunately, it's going to be us versus you for the boat.
And we're not going to we're not going to try to kill you.
We're not going to try to kill you, but if we're just going to put you in the boat and just leave.
You're the only boat like you're the only boat like.
And if you were to play the trout,
now you really want to play this.
I'm going to pull the button out.
Four of you, two of the six falls.
And it's like, you know, I'm already tired this day has been the worst day of my life.
Yeah, we already fucked up twice, bro.
Like, come on.
I don't want you guys.
We are not.
We don't have a boat.
We're just just asking for the right.
That's too much to ask.
We're all members of this.
The spiders never met.
What are you calling in?
Black winged, whatever.
What was it?
What are we called?
The blue one for the.
Yeah, the blue folds.
The lunar folds.
Are you sure you're going with that?
That's shit.
We're the shit show redemption.
Fuck you mean.
Do you want to go with the shit show redemption?
Well, it's up to you, Baptiste.
Whatever you say goes.
I mean, lunar fold.
Lunar fold pirates.
Now we're just a lunar fold.
Now pirates were just lunar folds.
But you are pirate.
But no, hey, we're just called the lunar fold.
You don't call us pirates because
it likes to call us.
Choose your lunar.
But they're like a mercenary group.
They don't they don't fight it.
As the as the crew, as of right now,
we haven't pirated anything.
But how it works, you're part of the black hand crew.
So you are supposed to be pirates.
Okay, we're the black queen bandits.
Okay.
Black.
This BB.
Yeah.
All right.
Lunar fold.
So I'm assuming you guys are with them.
Finally, it looks
oil in the ice and
when he says it.
And well, it goes.
Well, by guess for the time being,
he didn't consider me when he picked that name.
What do you say?
What?
What did he just say?
He said he didn't ask me before we picked that name,
but he said, I mean, okay,
but for the time being, I guess we are part of their crew.
Indeed you are.
Indeed I am friend.
He prints your shoulder as he goes.
Well, all aboard.
I'm going to you guys have food.
I hope.
Because I'm talking.
That's why we got it.
We got a scavenge for supplies real quick.
We got to make sure we have enough.
You can go out and maybe look for supplies,
but the I think they should have enough supplies
on the ship itself.
Perfect. Let's go.
Let's get on.
We'll get on.
Wheelcokeling looks back at Daniel as he goes.
Oh, by the way, where are the mobs?
And Daniel points one of the lower decks
as well quickly goes inside and just throws the mobs
in the bucket to Sirge as he goes.
Well, get on clean and
for the entire week, for the entire week.
I'm just screaming to her ears.
She goes, fuck you.
Leave me alone.
She just walks away.
And now you guys can.
Level.
All right.
Let me know if you're.
You're leveling up one one.
He said let me call my mom.
Is that what he said?
How do you fucking level up?
All right. I'm going to move you here, Roma, as well.
Great.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to share my screen.
And I'll level you up one by one.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Goes first.
Do you have any feeds for your subclass at level four or not?
I don't have a subclass right now.
So I don't even know.
How do you not have a subclass?
What do you mean?
You don't?
You have the box, sir.
I thought I gave you the box, sir.
That was a fee.
No, you're available in the open hands.
Yeah, you have a way of open hands.
Yeah.
I don't think that's what I had.
No, you have you have the box, sir.
I remember that's how you get your knockout punch.
I need to search the MD bro.
I need to stop doing this.
For the take.
It was one of the knockout right there.
That's level six.
Okay, now this is not the one one piece.
Which one did you send me?
I think you sent me the box or fee from somewhere.
We was in our channel for my character.
I don't know if I can look this though,
because I don't have access to it.
Oh, you don't have access to it.
Maybe you're fucking left.
That's why you don't have access to it.
Uh, you know, just get the slow falls.
What?
I'm almost just yet slow fall at level four.
Yeah, no, no, no, no, I just want to check if there's anything in like the
they got the box.
This is what you're saying.
You're a pusillist.
A feature knockout strike.
I think that was just the background in knockout strike was like a fee.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I'm sorry, sorry.
How did you not pick any subclass?
How are you functioning?
I think I did choose one and you said you would add it,
but you never ended up adding it.
Oh, my.
Stop.
Okay, there's no way.
I'll ask myself for my
where's the monk subclasses. The sheet is fucking insane. The class monk is supposed to be brawler, right?
Holy. Yeah, yeah. Six hours Master Ninja, which one of you are you ready? Shake it off.
What are you just a problem? How has your character been functioning so far? I don't understand.
I haven't used any subclasses name. I've just been using my punches in my race.
You know what? Just let me know whatever subclasses. I'll just level you up once. Okay, I'm going to ask again. Do you want to take average or do you want to roll?
Roll.
Two. What's the average five? Five. Yeah. I roll. I have ability score improvements. Where do you want to go?
Wait, who are you? You. Oh, I rolled a two anyway.
So I want to ability score or feet. You can do both I think. You should only be able to do one. No, he said both. No, he said both. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, it's not a lot of work. You said both. Okay. You can pick a feed out of whatever these are or you can ability score improved. Oh, I forgot your share your screen.
Yes. Alert. Archery. Alert. Can you just get alert? That's crazy. Yeah.
Yeah. Is it just add plus five? That's crazy. Yeah. What's the boom of foundation?
It increases one ability score of your choice by one to a maximum of 30. And peerless aim and gets you peerless aim.
Which is when you miss with an attacker, you can hit instead once you use this benefit, you can't use it again in the start of your next turn.
I would like the boom of combat prowess.
What this seems like. Are you broken? Oh, level 19. Sorry, sorry, it's a level 19 thing. Sorry. Yeah.
I didn't see the requirement. Sorry. Level 19. Level 19. You said anything that I can see. Level 19. Level 19.
Level 19. All right. You can choose defense. Why did it not just so fucking based on the level? Okay.
You can choose alert. You can choose archery, which I don't think you can.
You can choose defense. You know, why are you looking here? Just look where the normal level of stuff.
Yeah. Yeah. Just ddv. We're just go ddv.
Like all the books available to me. So.
There we go. Level 4. You get ability score improvement. Slow fall.
You get both, right? Yeah. Yeah. Slow fall does matter to us because we don't take fall damage anyway.
I love blue score improvements. Two points. Where do you want to put them?
Next parody. Both. Yep. All right. Next. Slow fall. There you go.
Go. I think that's it. Let me know about your subclass because I'm so confused as to what has been happening.
What is this? It is knockout and are not master. What is this?
Yeah. There you go. Boxers. The background. Okay. You're right. So what was saying?
Yeah. You can take a feed instead of a life. It's either.
Feet instead of ability score. Yeah. No. But if you the thing is you can choose either an ability to improve on or feeds.
Oh, I see. Do you want to pick a feed? Melthus? Sorry. Baptists. I keep continuing on.
You get us confused. That should be an ability score.
That's a lot of everything.
An arm movement plus 10 feet. What?
No, that's the total. Okay. I was like, what the fuck? It has plus 10. I realize that's crazy.
Three points to four. So I think that automatically updates. I don't think I have to change that.
Is it updated? Yeah. It is updated. Okay.
I mean, I already added the ability score. So it's too late now. All right. Next is.
I'm not sure if you're going to choose anymore. Bob. Yeah. Yeah. Bob. Let's go.
What does it cost? Bob have? I'm kind of curious.
Do you want to take average Bob or do you want to?
Roll? Just a roll for Bob.
Oh, hey, I'm out. Can you do a others first? Okay.
Is all rolling for it? Fuck me. Let's do it. Yeah. Mouthless.
You want a roll take average? Yes. Roll. Of course. It's a D8. Right? Yes.
Let's do that.
Four, which is, you know, not that bad. All things considered.
All right. Ability score of feet. What feet do you want if you want to feed?
All right. I'll just do next. And then we can add the feed later. All right. Just let me know.
All right. Roma. I know level four is not that, you know, crazy because there's nothing you guys.
He can get a surplus. Yeah. That is true. All right. That's it. Two.
Which? First level barbarian. First level barbarian.
First level. Which one do you want to increase?
Yeah. D12 roll D12 instead.
If you're barbarian, first it should be D12. You're hit. Oh, what's it?
You're in level three barbarian. What's up class? Damn.
Yeah. Go.
Do you think about your subclass? Which one you want? Yeah. I want the berserker.
Then we see path of the berserker. Select. Complete. You get frenzy.
And that's it. I think all of the stuff got automatically added.
And two at hax. Now we're almost going to do two more damage with the skillet. Let's go.
I think I have a plus two now. I'm not going straight. I go.
I had one point you will have perfect. It's quite easy to make this actually valuable.
And the first one is five.
Did I not get to choose if I wanted to put it into like strength or whatever?
No, there's no level four. I don't think that's on level four. Yeah. Yeah.
Perfect. You are only level three and one in fighter.
Yep.
Are Bob, you're the only one left until then. Malphys, are you figuring out what skill you want?
Almost.
All right.
I'm going to be really glad to make my text magical with the feet.
No, what the fuck is this to at their level you choose a path.
And I don't think any of the people on the ship level hockey.
What?
As much as we were hyping up, getting a level, I don't think I was prepared to actually level up.
Yeah, exactly. Bro, what the fuck have you not looked at your character sheet?
Okay, let me see.
Fourth level ability score improvements. Fifth, you get a devil fruit upgrade.
Bit level.
Yeah, you do get an extra attack for monks. I'm just talking in general like devil fruit class table.
I'm looking at a fifth level you get third tier. Six, you get nothing except for your class stuff.
Seven to get hockey choice.
I want my devil fruit ability to have my.
What's what was those punches called?
I don't know if I can give you that that's too much.
It's four damage.
It is four damage with it, you know, adds up everything adds up.
Can I get the mobile feet?
Let me see. Can you get the mobile feet month?
Yeah.
Mobile.
Open hands monk.
No, no, just just for my feet.
Everyone can take mobile.
Yeah, I know, I know. I'm just checking.
I just people complaining over it.
Okay, everyone's complaining about it, I guess.
I'm sorry.
You're exceptionally speedy and agile you gain benefits speed and crazy 10 feet when you dash action.
Difficult terrain doesn't cost you an extra movement on that turn and make a melee against the creature you don't provoke opportunity.
I guess from the creature for the rest of the turn, whenever you hit or not.
Okay, I see what you're doing.
I see, I see mobile.
It's not a thing here.
All right.
If it's in the if it's in normal players handbook, then why is it not?
Okay.
Character.
No, not species.
Wouldn't it be under feet?
Monk.
There's a features.
That's not a class feature.
I'm not looking at feeds.
Origin feeds.
General feeds fighting style feeds.
What the hell are the fucking feeds?
The class is up last feeds.
It's not a surplus feature.
It's just a feed is just a normal feed or a monster feed or anything.
Is it a monster feed or?
No, it's just a normal feed.
I see, I see, I see.
I'll just copy based in a feature.
There we go.
Sorry.
All right.
Let me effect.
No effects.
There we go.
Attribute.
Oh, sorry.
Mobile.
Attribute increases.
Walk.
Add.
I'll add fly as well.
Fly.
And plus five.
And.
I think flies.
The same as your movement.
So if you're moving increases, your fly also increases.
I thought we were doing half of our movement for fly though.
So is your thing increased for now?
Yeah.
I was 25 first now.
It's 50 and 35.
All right.
Cool.
I think I was putting like half on the base speed.
If you're a monk.
We had this question in our party.
Yeah.
So I'm going to be right now.
I was fly speed.
It was 25.
Now it's 35.
What's yours?
I'm pleased.
Only.
Let me see.
20.
What your walk is.
What?
So it should be 15.
40 walk and 25.
That's correct.
Right.
It should be half of.
It's 20.
I'm confused.
Yeah.
I think it's fine.
I don't know.
I give up.
Bobby.
We level up.
Yeah.
Present.
All right.
Do you want to level up?
I think so.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you want to roll for the health or do you want to make average?
I know what look.
I don't want to roll.
You can choose a feat.
You want to take the point.
What?
I'll choose a feat.
Can I take fair touch?
I take fair touch.
See.
Because I need that Mr. Step.
I need to get out.
I need to run.
I do.
I'm pressing a time.
I don't have.
You need fireball.
Yeah.
Change your element.
It's from Tasha.
Of course, you're not here.
I'm going to just add a feature.
I'm going to use the feature.
What's the poison?
Bob, your suppose is great.
There you go.
Hey, well, this magic has changed.
You're learning the following abilities.
Increases your intelligence and wisdom and charisma score.
Which one do you want to increase?
St.
Hold.
No, I hit you.
Sorry.
What was it?
Increase this.
I hit you.
It's one.
Or.
It's true.
Bob is not chewing.
You learn Mr. Steps spell.
You can cast one first level spell of your choice.
The first level spell must be from divination or enchantment school.
You can cast each of these spells without expending a slot.
Once you cast either of these spells in this way, you can't cast that spell in this way until you finish a long rest.
You can also cast these spells.
Using spells loss, you have appropriate level.
You can cast that spell in this way.
Bob.
Mr. Step.
He already has Mr. Steps, wasn't he?
Yeah, you can cast his profile now.
Oh, I see.
He can't switch it out if he gets new spells.
How many spells is Bob has?
He has a lot of spells.
I don't think he has all of this prepared though.
But you can only prepare certain amounts.
How many did he have?
Seven.
Seven prepared.
Let me see which one he had prepared.
Burning hands.
Told the dead minor, new vision, mending.
Yeah, this is a counter.
Mimic sphere.
Merry image.
Mr. Step.
He's gone.
So we can take the missing stuff away.
And add something else.
Yeah.
I don't know why I added additional.
It's part of his that ability.
You can take it if you want.
Drop it in again.
That's what it's here.
What the fuck?
I don't know.
Bob, we can't hear you.
You're speaking.
No.
Also, you forgot.
Yeah, now I can.
Ability score, which one you wanted and.
Oh, my God, Baptiste is just looking.
Oh, my, I did not mean to do that.
I was trying to view it and I was like, why is it opening?
For five.
Yeah, Bob, go ahead, go ahead.
Which one, which ability you want to increase in with a Christmas?
I just hear.
Bob just takes that.
Let's take like in the chat, just say what you want.
Bob died.
Also, you keep forgetting the second part of the flame spirit.
What?
The second part?
Yeah, there's a second part of the flaming sphere at the end of everyone's turn within five feet of flaming sphere.
Oh, yeah, I don't think you did it.
No, no, you need to look at Bob.
Bob spells Bob as flaming sphere.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, I'm going to.
Thanks, fear.
I can move this fear.
The last part.
The creature takes the end of the adventure.
The end of the sphere.
Ignites the end of the objects.
And it's just.
And it's turned within five feet of the sphere.
Or make it that saving throw.
It's not the end of the beginning.
Oh, yeah, okay.
Any creature that ends its turn within five feet of that sphere makes the Dixerty saving.
Huh, I didn't see that.
My internet hates me.
Okay, now you're good.
Let's get this over with.
Okay, in twist them Christmas, in probably.
Yeah.
I need more pain.
Take that to each.
And.
What do you want?
Okay, I'll get Mr. Steps.
And that's always prepared.
Can I do some very bugs?
You can only the first level of value must be from the Vination or Enchantment School of Magic.
It's from Enchantment.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, yeah.
Enchantment.
First level.
Yep.
Silvery Barb's again.
Please be here.
It's not here.
Wow.
I'll just now I'll just add that here just so I remember.
Little rebarps.
I'll fill the details and later actually.
Okay.
We'll be based for now.
And then we can fill the details.
Oh, yeah.
This is fucking pissing me off.
Oh, he's in.
Oh, yeah, I'll get another country.
No, you can't get.
I don't think so.
Yeah, but you don't get the country level four.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Wizard.
He can change his cantrips.
He can change one.
It says cantrips know.
Four.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, I really need an expel.
So let's go fireball.
Oh, come on.
Just get fireball.
Oh, there you go.
I need you to either go.
Psychic.
What idiot poison.
I think I get.
Four.
And I pick.
And I pick chromatic or band.
No, not chromatic.
And I pick mind spike and absorb elements.
Oh, wait, are we doing 2014 or 2014?
14.
Okay, so no mind spike.
Absorb elements and chromatic.
I'm sorry.
Oh, no, it's not here.
And chromatic or I have this.
I'll add absorb elements.
Sorry.
Oh,
I'm in.
We're on the year tax due bludgeoning damage.
With the pan.
Yeah.
That does.
an
impressive
definite
bert
feedback
looking
uh you have 7 prepared so
prepare
I'll just turn my punches to piercing damage instead.
We're min vaccine all of the crew combined.
No one's min vaccine.
No, it's fine.
All right, so I'm going to be real with you.
I thought the boss battle will last long, last lot longer.
So I think I'm just going to end it about it.
We already had four hours, so I'm probably going to end here.
Wait.
There's one thing I have to do.
Oh, I get a blow down.
They're invincible now.
Come on, we got it.
Well, we got to be on the sea.
So like, if we don't be out there, like you know what I'm saying?
You want to blow it up?
I'm OK.
I get a big one.
I have a big red button.
I've been waiting to push.
I want to make sure we're far enough away.
Push the big red button.
Just let me know.
I'm pushing it.
Push it.
All right.
So you're far away from the island I'm assuming.
No one's going to want it.
Well, we'll check it.
You push the button.
Can you--
What are my rolling fork?
Roll for fun, I guess.
Roll that safe.
Roll it to 100.
Roll a nuke.
What's a roll for a nuke?
What is it?
20?
Far away.
Our roll is right now.
What is it?
Oh!
75 million d6 damage, no.
75 d6, say less.
255.
Whatever.
As you push the button, you kind of see
like the center of wherever the core was.
You see in the direction of where the core was.
The island starts to fall in and deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper.
All of the platforms starts to crumble
as the pieces of the islands just start
to submerge within as this radiant energy is starting
to pull the islands inside.
And after a few minutes, it's just nothing there.
All of it submerged completely.
Zero.
That's fucking dope.
I told you we would destroy this island.
Did not.
I did.
All right.
This is where we'll end the session.
Come up with an interesting way of how you leveled up.
Basically, like what you were doing in between
like traveling from this place to on the next island.
You go to.
I was met at the end.
I was a month down.
I fed you the greatest meal of all time.
I got faster.
I was running away from it.
Yeah, you go faster because you were running away from me.
Every lunch.
Well, I didn't behind you.
I was just wondering what you were doing.
Anyway, where are we supposed to be...
Page 1, though.
He's supposed to be weaker than Zerka.
Hey, I'm just going to say this, though.
Hey, I'm just saying this, though.
Bab. Not do that again. It's just a friendly Bob. Come on. Hi brother. You ain't gonna die. You ain't gonna die.
You ain't gonna die. It's all knock out blowing. It's all knock out blowing. That's my own record.
You know. But depending on your mother. Yeah. Sticked for your manly hood man.
He wants to know the ranking of the crew members. Like.
And and me and circle get a rematch bro. Like. Yeah. Let's go.
Seconds place. No, he just gets a buy in the first round. It's it's draw the straw.
He got no. I was gonna do losers can still fight the next person. Cause it's so winter around one
between circle round with bell Bob. They're gonna have to fight each other. So that
means nothing gets another bite. Unless we do another role to see you get second round. Okay, let's
let's do another role. We have to see who wins first. Yeah. The loser don't run from around.
Okay, after after round one. So that's the round one. It'll be it'll be Malfus. Bob or Malfus and then the
winner of Bob. Winner of Bob and well.
Worst winner of fight two. So then those three winners like those three winners were roll again.
All right. Yeah. And we're against the buy. Yeah. And then the rest two fight again.
Yep. Yep. Those two fight. And then it'll be those two fighting. And that will be whoever that
winner right there. Cause he's the winner of everything is whatever the highest one was that he said.
I'm probably not sure. It's probably like. And then round two. It's another roll off.
Like. No, it's just find around right. Yeah. No, it's just find around after the buy second round.
Yeah. So winner of round two versus whoever got the buy from round two.
Right. Yeah. So whoever loses round two gets third place.
Two versus winner of round no buy for on two. And all of this way.
Other this. And rankings would be whoever wins the final round is the second in hand.
The third in command would be winner from two and the fourth in command would be the last person.
Bob, I'm rooting for you. Okay. Don't listen to these assholes.
I think we're all rooting for Bob. Yeah. I'm not voting for.
Look, you can use your intelligence, right? Bob, you know, you can work around it. Yeah.
Bob just walks in and he's like, hey guys, I give up. Oh, Bob could forfeit. You know, Bob could forfeit.
And then mouth is just like fuck it. I'm fighting. Yeah. If you want to join competition.
And air could roam for a few days. Don't stop without coming out to see the sun.
Bob is all in for that.
All right.
Shit. Let's see where the story goes and let's see if you find it. That's what I'll say.
You worry about that while we're worried about who, how are we going to fight this?
And Bob, you're out. How he's going to fucking handle Vilt. Look.
Can miss just step now. So I know what I'm doing.
Never do you say big dog. Are we resting by the way? Yeah, you probably are long resting.
So Tuesday then, right? BG3?
Oh, that means I want to. Yeah, the time is also a big issue.
Let's see. Let's see.
Tuesday's on our food days. What am I saying?
I have a high hope. Just let me know a time.
I mean, I'm free basically all day. So I worked so much.
Oh, wait. What did you say?
Tuesday.
My baller.
I'm going to go. Okay. No. Yeah. What it comes today?
I thought we were both session. Never. No, no, no. We're not doing next week session. We're going next to next.
It gives him a chance to downscale. Fail. Are you okay? Yeah.
And figure out where he put our boat. I mean, I know where I put your boat.
Did you read through what happened while you were guy you guys were traveling through reverse mountain?
Yes.
My God, did you not catch it? Oh, my God.
That's Sarah. Can I hit one thing and then the sales opened?
No. Yeah. Yeah. Oh.
Sorry, sorry, sorry. Yeah. That was the thing. Bob disappearing with Mr.
said the moment we were.
Sirica did something. I don't let me let me read through it again.
Did I add it to down time? I don't know.
Do we have is our fruit? Is our ship a double fruit user?
On the sea? Let's ship ship. No, me.
I must smack you.
Looking at over the skillet.
Well, inanimate objects can also eat delifers, correct?
Yeah.
As long as the inanimate object in question is not in contact with the sea itself.
But wouldn't a boat be in the eating contact?
Oh, no, it can be the searing.
It's the anchor.
The anchor has to go water.
So it could be the whole upper half of the boat.
It could be anything.
It could be like it could literally just be one thing.
Like it could like you said, just be the sales.
They caused the fucking boat. It could be just the fucking captain's wheel.
Who know? It could be all the fucking the fireman's light.
Sure. How it works for inanimate objects, honestly.
It's just the person who ate a double fruit and turned into a ship.
Yeah, but that one work. I feel like they've been trapped in that form forever.
Do you remember about like what
Bramble said about the ship?
Like he found the ship somewhere and then they just got it like a couple days ago.
Just repair it.
I don't remember that.
Yeah, I do.
But like he just got it.
He got it, but he found the boat at like somewhere near River Smountain.
He didn't say anything. He just said he just got the boat.
No, no, he did mention something with the River Smountain.
Well, that's fine. We got well, we got to go to River Smountain.
We got to go north.
You get to go back to the River Smountain.
Yeah, we're following the boat.
We're getting it funny.
All the time, we're just going.
Oh, let's go to the east.
Let's go to the ground.
Let's go to the east.
So funny.
Like how I finally tried to progress.
Mouth is his storyline with his sister.
Yeah.
And then we know she is, but the ship is gone.
Alrighty.
I'll see you guys next week.
Yeah, not next week.
I'll be back.